bon
[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
sur public sénat pour un nouveau numéro
des matins du sénat les missions qui
vous fait vivre les travaux de la haute
assemblée dans un instant la commission
d' enquête du sénat sur la gestion de la
crise du coronavirus va auditionner
xavier bertrand président de la région
ile de france et ancien ministre de la
santé
entre 2005 et 2007 et entre 2010 et 2012
xavier bertrand a notamment géré la
grippe h1n1 en 2010
il a donc une expérience à faire valoir
devant les sénateurs en matière de
gestion de crise sanitaire
je vous laisse écouter cette audition
alors monsieur le ministre vous avez été
chargée de la santé à deux reprises vous
avez été confronté la première fois à
une épidémie importante la pandémie de
grippe aviaire h5n1 qui a donné lieu à
l'élaboration d'une doctrine d'emploi et
de stockage des masques dans notre pays
cette doctrine d'emploi très large eux
devaient être servis par l'eprus
établissement de préparation et de
réponse aux urgences sanitaires eprus
qui a été créée par une loi du 5 mars
2007 sur cette question de la doctrine
d'emploi des masses comme votre deuxième
expérience ministérielle est marqué par
l'avis du haut conseil de santé publique
de 2011 avis qui opère un premier retour
d'expérience et préconise de réserve et
l'emploi des masques ffp2 aux seuls
soignants et non plus aux professionnels
dit dans la crise sanitaire connu
comprenez sont actuellement
professionnels de deuxième ligne
voilà ffp2 pour les premières lee nous
avons eu l'occasion d'évoquer ces
périodes avec les professeur didier
houssin alors directeur général de la
santé et délégué interministériel à la
lutte contre la grippe aviaire également
avec un ancien dgs
jean yves grall monsieur le ministre
vous avez été entendu longuement pendant
près de trois heures par la commission d
enquête de l'assemblée nationale c'était
le 2 juillet dernier
vous avez développé une vision très
régaliennes des questions de santé
et notamment de la responsabilité de
l'état en cas de crise sanitaire
vous avez plaidé pour un certain
volontarisme politique rappelant que
vous aviez en particulier en matière
d'arbitrage budgétaire reçu le soutien
sans faille du président de la
république pour constituer des stocks
j'aurais pour ma part quatre remarques
ou interrogations en écho à vos
déclarations avant de passer la parole
au rapporteur
même si nous sommes toujours dans la
crise nous nous interrogeons sur ce que
doit être la préparation du pays par
temps calme en l'absence de pandémie ou
en période d'épisodes moins aigu que
prévu n'y at il pas une forme de
fatalité à désarmer notamment dans un
pays dont les finances publiques sont
très dégradées ne faut-il pas dès lors
imaginer un système où le stockage des
équipements de protection seraient
davantage décentralisée première
remarque ensuite l'action très
volontaire de l'âge élections de h5n1
qui s'est notamment traduite par l'envoi
aux professionnels libéraux de kits de
protection n'appelle pas en fait envoyé
à tous le message du de quoi qu'il
arrive l'état et là nous avons constaté
que d'autres anciens ministres avaient
une vision peut être différente sur ce
point qu'il s'agisse de roselyne
bachelot ou de marisol touraine
autre point vous avez déclaré le
logisticien c'est un sacré métier
nous ne pouvons que vous rejoindre en
tout cas au cours de nos auditions s'est
rendu compte de l'importance de la
logistique et nous avons constaté même
que lorsqu'il y avait des masques l'état
et ses agences étaient incapables de les
acheminer sur le terrain pensez vous que
l'eprus qui n'a jamais eu à le faire
grandeur nature aurait su faire cette
distribution
enfin vous avez évoqué le changement de
doctrine du sgdn
le service général défense et de
sécurité nationale en 2013
que d'aucuns rentrer responsable de la
pénurie de masques
il semble que cette doctrine du sgdn
maintient la responsabilité de l'état en
présence d'une maladie infectieuse
hautement contagieuse à transmission
respiratoires une définition bien
précise
est ce un changement de doctrine recul
des priorités en l'absence de menace
immédiate c'est en tout cas la question
que nous sommes en droit de nous poser
alors comme il est de tradition les
auditions je vais vous laisser la parole
pendant cinq 5 7 minutes
on n'est pas voilà mais relativement
bref je dirais dans les propos
introductifs pour laisser la place bien
sûr aux questions des rapporteurs trois
rapporteurs et ensuite aux questions
groupe et de nos commissaires mais avant
bien sûr procédures applicables aux
commission denquête vous rappeler que
tout témoignage mensonger devant une
commission est susceptible d'une amende
de 60 kg une 1000 euros et d'une peine
de prison allant jusqu'à 5 ans et vous
demandez bien sûr de prêter serment de
dire la vérité toute la vérité levé la
main droite et dit je le jure
on appuie sur le petit bouton voilà je
jure de dire toute la vérité
merci eh bien écoutez garder le micro
ouvert et enchaîner avec votre propos
limitait remercie monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs tout d'abord mes
excuses
cinq minutes de retard 5 7 minutes de
retard j'en suis désolé je pourrais vous
parler des conditions de trajet sera au
mieux une explication mais en rien une
excuse donc je vous prie d'accepter
d'accepter les miennes très sincèrement
très sincèrement monsieur le président
vous voulez vous que je réponde d'ores
et déjà à vos questions et remarques ou
voulez vous que je fasse au fur et à
mesure où à la fin comme vous le
souhaitez écoutez vous ne vous ne mettez
pas de répondre et vous le faites comme
vous l'entendez
alors ce que je vous propose c'est
peut-être si je n'y ai pas répondu de
finir par vos questions pour être sûr de
bien reboucler et donc je me tiens à la
disposition des déjà des rapporteurs et
des sénateurs face on vient leur propos
liminaire nous pouvons procéder comme
cela
pour les questions j'attendais un propos
liminaire
non je vous propose de répondre
directement aux questions a très bien si
vous voulez mais pas de problème donc je
vais passer la parole au rapporteur nous
allons commencer par caroline des rushes
après sylvie ou fermier puis bernard
jomier répondre il va répondre
après donc je sais que je peux a
perturbé c'était juste pour revenir sur
vos questions tout à fait tout à fait
c'est un c'est pas illogique de penser
aussi par les questions du rapporteur
mais soyez assuré que je veillerai à ce
que avoir une réponse aux questions que
j'ai formulée bien entendu vous pouvez
là-dessus me semble-t-il me faire
confiance
catherine des roches voilà merci merci
monsieur le ministre de rentrer
directement dans les questions moi
j'avais plusieurs questions la première
c'est lorsque vous étiez en charge de la
santé vous avez eu à gérer donc des
épisodes d'épidémie quels étaient les
organismes sur lesquels vous appuyer
pour prendre vos décisions
si vous pouvez nous les sites et
pourquoi je pose cette question parce
que bon ici là il ya eu la mise en place
du conseil scientifique mais également
des déclarations très précoce de la
ministre de la santé
nous informons que le virus avait très
peu de risque d'arriver en france et on
souhaite savoir qu'elle était à ce
moment là les organismes qu'il avait
donné les éléments pour pour qu'elle
fasse cette affirmation donc comment
vous travaillez lorsque vous été
ministre avec qui et comment ce zèle et
les liens étroits normalement entre dgs
et et vous même votre cabinet le
deuxième question une question là où je
m'adresse au président de région
ce que l'on voit au cours de ses
auditions c'est qui il manque parfois un
retour d'expérience de la part de de
l'état sur sur ce qui s'est passé
pendant la crise et
et et qui peut servir justement puisque
le virus continue à circuler
nous ne sommes plus sur une épidémie
passé mais sur une épidémie encore en
activité donc allez vous le retour
d'expérience au niveau de votre région
de points saillants du retour
d'expérience que vous avez et comment ça
se traduit dans l'action régionale
actuellement on a vu la place importante
des collectivités locales aux cours de
cette crise à côté des drs et des
préfets et votre expérience de de
président d'une grande région est
intéressante d'une région qui en plus a
eu quand même des foyers importants est
importante pour nous et pour les
préconisations que l'on pourra faire je
vous remercie monsieur le ministre
merci madame la rapporteur sur qui on
s'appuie principalement sur la direction
générale de la santé et le directeur
général de la santé qui plus est j'ai eu
la chance de travailler avec un
directeur remarquable didier houssin
j'ai toujours veillé dans mes
différentes fonctions ministérielles à
ce que mon cabinet ne fasse pas écran
par rapport aux directions sur
différentes questions clés surtout en
gestion de crise il faut non pas qui est
fluidité et fauqué une interpénétration
entre le cabinet et la dgs et la ds les
cabinets ministériels n'avait pas la
même taille qu'aujourd'hui mais nous
avons eu a notamment philippe
douste-blazy aussi avant moi jusqu'à
sept conseillers dans le domaine
sanitaire sept conseillers dans le
domaine de la sécurité sanitaire et j'ai
déjà eu l'occasion de le dire d'avoir
réduit à ce point les effectifs des
cabinets n'a pas été une erreur ça a été
une faute a été une faute parce que en
tout état de cause vous ne permettez pas
également aux ministres n'ont pas
d'avoir une liberté d'analysé des
expertises un devoir mais d'avoir aussi
des conseillers qui ont le temps d'avoir
le dialogue avec la dgs mais d'autres
organismes
notre organisme c'est la question de
l'afssaps et la question du haut conseil
pour la santé publique
voilà les principaux organismes qui ont
un travail et puis derrière vous avez
plusieurs possibilités soit vous décidez
de créer une nouvelle instance et donc
vous fragilisez celles qui existent
en remettant en cause leur légitimité or
elles n'ont pas été créées sur un sur un
coup de tête
ou alors vous avez quelque chose d'un
formelle que vous mettez en place et qui
vous permet justement d'avoir un regard
pardonnez-moi à 361 degrés j'ai déjà eu
l'occasion d'exprimer et je voudrais le
dire également au président je n'ai pas
eu à affronter une crise sanitaire comme
celle que nous avons connue lac est
d'une ampleur inégalée
je vais affronter différentes crises
sanitaires notamment celle qu'est les
habitants de la réunion était confronté
avec le chikungunya
une autre dimension d'autres notamment
comme quoi comme la dengue en guyane et
aux antilles mais j'ai eu surtout à
préparer le pays c'était la
responsabilité qui m'avait été confiée
par dominique de villepin et jacques
chirac notamment par rapport à ce que
l'on voyait auparavant à face que l'on
voyait en asie h5n1 nous avons été
confrontés avec le remarquable rôle de
roselyne bachelot a h1n1 mais h5n1 ce
n'est pas la même chose à chaque état il
y avait un taux de létalité tels que ça
nous obligerait à prendre un grand
nombre de mesures drastiques à l'époque
à l'époque et donc nous avions vu qu'il
y à qu'il y avait ce risque non pas
d'une transmission de l'animal à l'homme
s'était avéré mais une transmission de
l'homme à l'homme ou là les conditions
de propagation et les conditions de
létalité étaient absolument dramatiques
nous avions un plan quand je suis arrivé
jeune ministre en juin 2005 et un plan
qui honnêtement sur le papier avait fort
belle allure et il s'avère que jolie
journal du dimanche une interview un
article de deux professeurs jean
philippe derenne françois bricaire qui
nous disent grosso modo que notre plan
c'est un bon plan sur le papier mais
qu'il tiendra pas la route en cas
d'épidémie revenons au ministère le
lendemain je demande à les rencontrer et
home le déconseille alain faut pas les
voir cela ce sont des râleurs sera ainsi
le niveau acceptable
ce sont des râleurs il faut pas les voir
je demande à les voir petit déjeuner qui
avait été organisée et avant même de
commencer jean philippe derenne son
style inimitable ni monsieur le ministre
j'ai une série de questions moi vous
poser avant de répondre votre thé pas
trop dans les usages
mais d'ailleurs je suis plus froid que
quelqu'un passe un papier en disant je
vous l'avais dit d'accord qui se
comportaient comme ça et je m'aperçois à
la deuxième question qu'ils me posent
que j'ai pas les réponses et pourtant
j'avais un peu regardé potasser et là je
me suis rendu compte que ce plan n'était
pas à hauteur des gens des
professionnels de santé de ceux qui
auraient en charge l'organisation du
pays est aussi des patients c'était un
excellent plan sur le papier mais il
fallait faire attention à ce qu'on
comment dirais-je on rembourse cette
ossature qu'on lui donne une dimension
concrète est particulièrement efficace
la question des déplacements par exemple
la façon dont les professionnels de
santé à l'époque on n'avait pas encore
les zooms les skype ou hôte pourrait à
distance parce qu'il ne rentrerait pas
chez eux continuent à avoir un une
relation avec leur famille les risques
de contagion
la prise en charge des patients avec un
système qui qui bien évidemment
risquaient d'être submergés très vite et
ils m'ont donné ce regard est donc
j'avais décidé alors on s'est aussi
appuyé parce que un ministre n'arrive
jamais en partant d'une page blanche et
beaucoup de choses qui ont été faites
avant lui et notamment il rapport
notamment de didier raoul qui avait fait
notamment sur d'autres risques que les
seuls risques épidémiques sur lequel
nous puissions nous appuyer et on a
complètement revue l'architecturé et le
contenu du plan en faisant également un
grand nombre d'exercices qui n'étaient
en rien des jeux mais qui était aussi
une façon de s'approprier toutes les
situations
nombre de situations que l'on n'avait
pas images imaginées et c'est comme ça
que l'on a préparé ce plan et c'est
comme ça que l'om est ce à un moment
donné a indiqué je veux dire de cette
façon que nous étions la france était
l'un des pays les mieux préparés mais
préparés personne n'aurait pu traverser
l'épidémie sans qu'il n'y ait des
victimes sans qu'il n'y ait de fortes
tensions et sans qu'il n'y ait des
difficultés personne peut dire c'est pas
parce qu'on était préparée que ça se
serait bien passé ça peut jamais bien se
passer de façon à partir du moment où il
ya un drame des disparitions quand il y
à des malades quand il ya des soignants
qui sont submergés travail ça peut pas
bien se passer
mais la question c'est de savoir si on
est un dans l'anticipation et deux dans
la protection
donc je n'ai pas voulu créé d'entités
mais par contre j'avais
un groupe autour de moi qui me
permettait de répondre à des questions
qu'elles participaient également didier
houssin et mon cabinet pour voir ce à
quoi nous n'avions pas pensé
c'est ça je pense le le rôle c'est
d'essayer d'imaginer ce qui ne semble
pas forcément très rationnel et encore
une fois même en faisant ça vous n'avez
pas la réponse à 100% des problèmes en
permanence il innovait donc voilà
comment nous nous avions voulu
fonctionner mais par contre lui un point
qui est important qu'elles que soient
les comités la responsabilité politique
ne se partage pas et elle ne se délègue
pas c'est à dire que vous avez des avis
de scientifiques qu'ils savent des
choses qui ne savent pas tout il faut
effectivement en avoir conscience
mais au final c'est le politique va le
politique le la politique qui décide et
qui doit assumer ses responsabilités
notre système politico administratif
français était tellement marquée par des
drames certains scandales où on a donné
le sentiment que le politique s'exonérer
de sa responsabilité pour bien
comprendre aujourd'hui que cette
responsabilité
elle est une et indivisible ensuite sur
la question du retour d'expérience va
vous marquez vous touchez du doigt l'un
des vrais problèmes politico
administratif français
nous n'avons pas la culture de
l'évaluation nous n'avons pas la culture
de la correction de trajectoire et
encore une fois encore une fois
l'anticipation est plus facile d'en
parler que de vraiment réussir à
traduire l'anticipation c'est la clé
c'est la clé et d'ailleurs je souhaite
effectivement savoir ce qui a été fait
en termes de retours d'expérience après
cette première vague
je ne sais pas s'il y aura divulgation
communication sis à partir de là des
nouveaux protocoles ont été établis pour
l'ensemble des professionnels de santé
en établissements hôpitaux publics comme
clinique mais également pour l'ensemble
des professionnels en cabinet en cabinet
pour les deux parce que je ne vous cache
pas que ce retour d'expérience va être
particulièrement utile pour une simple
et bonne raison c'est que nous allons
avoir dès maintenant à la rentrée des
circonstances qui peuvent être
particulièrement inquiétante
la reprogrammation de l'ensemble des
interventions qui ont été différées
on sait pourquoi elles ont été différées
il fallait en différé un grand nombre
mais elles sont aujourd'hui reporter on
ne peut pas avoir une perte de chance
pour les personnes qui ont besoin de ces
interventions pour un certain nombre de
traitements et puis vous avez également
la conjonction de la grippe saisonnière
il faut pas oublier que normalement
normalement naughton et à l'hiver nos
établissements de santé nos
professionnels de santé sont
naturellement normalement surchargé à
cause de ces affections
et donc je plaide pour qu'il y ait
maximum d'anticipation sur la
coordination médecine de ville et
campagne établissements mais que surtout
le système de vaccination grippe
saisonnière cette année soit clairement
anticiper au maximum pas seulement sur
les commandes de vaccins sur la mise en
oeuvre de cette politique vaccinale et
encore et encore une fois de façon à
pouvoir dire aux gens vaccinez vous au
maximum cette année parce que si vous
pensez avoir avec des symptômes la
grippe saisonnière et que vous avez là
qu'ovide c'est pas du tout la même chose
pour des raisons de contagiosité
évidente
donc je sais aujourd'hui quelles sont
les questions qui sont posées sur les
les vaccins haute mais il faut
clairement que le gouvernement que
l'assurance-maladie engage tout de suite
une campagne de vaccination maximum
positive positive en expliquant pourquoi
chaque année ça vaut la peine
mais que cette année plus encore ça nous
permettra d'éviter la conjonction de ces
deux phénomènes
parce que si ça n'est pas le cas vous
allez avoir des médecins libéraux qui
vont être complètement surchargé
plus encore que d'habitude et aussi un
système hospitalier ne l'oublions pas
dans certaines circonstances et dans
certains établissements
vous avez aux mamans pic de grippe
saisonnière beaucoup de lits de
réanimation qui sont occupés par des
patients liés à la grippe saisonnière et
vous savez aussi les ravages en termes
sanitaires les disparitions liés à la
grippe saisonnière
donc ce phénomène qu vide dans une
nouvelle nouvelle approche chez passion
doit parler de vague ou pas et grippe
saisonnière c'est quelque chose de
particulièrement important concernant la
région main posé la question
il faut savoir que les présidents de
région sont pas les seuls des présentes
département également et aussi beaucoup
de maires se sont clairement en
clairement engagée au côté de l'état on
nous a dit ça la place de l'état non
c'est pas la place de l'état c'était
tout simplement pour aider et protéger
les habitants nos territoires respectifs
c'est ça qu'on a voulu faire mais notre
compétence en matière sanitaire n'existe
pas moi moi je souhaiterais avoir
davantage de compétences en matière de
santé mais en revanche je les ai indiqué
tout ce qui est veille sanitaire
tout ce qui est la sécurité sanitaire
c'est la sphère de l'état parce
qu'autrement vous avez de vraies
difficultés de vraies différences de
prise en charge regardez ce qui s'est
passé en italie
c'est parti en italie dans certaines
provinces parce que le vaccin gouverneur
ou un président gouverneurs de région
ils ont la compétence n'a pas voulu
engager une politique de prévention de
prise en charge de dépistage parce qu'il
ne voulait pas pointé du doigt telle ou
telle catégorie de sa population et
c'est pour ça que dans ces cas là il
faut qu'il y ait une autorité et c'est
l'autorité de l'état qui permet de
garantir à l'est les mêmes chances pour
chacun et qui permet justement de
prendre les mesures qui s'imposent donc
voyez nous n'avons pas cette compétence
en revanche on a fait un retour
d'expérience sur la façon dont nos
services se sont adaptés les questions
de télétravail celles et ceux qui ont
permis que le télétravail parce que du
jour au lendemain
télétravail c'est bien mais il a fallu
aussi assurer la livraison des
ordinateurs à ceux qui restaient
confinés chez eux
comment vous gérez notamment celles et
ceux qui ont des affections de longue
durée qui sont fragiles comme on voulait
rassurer
j'ai moi même fait un grand nombre de
facebook live avec l'ensemble des agents
pour leur expliquer leur apporter des
indications sur ce que nous savions sur
ce que nous ne savions pas et d'autre
part il ya eu la question de la mise à
disposition des masques
j'aurais certainement l'occasion d'y
revenir notamment suite à
l'interpellation du président tout à
l'heure avec l'opération un masque pour
tous ou dans la région j'ai souhaité que
nous puissions mettre à disposition pour
commencer une première dotation de
masques réutilisables où je tape pour
l'ensemble de la population
c'est avec ce retour d'expérience à
notre niveau et dans notre seule
compétence que je peux vous apporter des
éléments mais ce retour d'expérience
bousquet de ce qu'a été cette première
vague et
indispensable pour pouvoir faire face à
la suite parce que nous n'aurons
l'occasion de parler de ce virus au
passé que quand nous aurons le vaccin
qu'ovide pas avant pas avant merci c'est
mon catherine des roches sylvie
vermeillet merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre vous avez déclaré
début juillet à l'assemblée nationale
tout un système s'est fait bouffer la
tête par une logique court termiste et
budgétaires alors avec votre expérience
de ministre de la santé j'aimerais vous
reveniez sûr sur cette expression bien
sûr la gestion des masques des stocks
stratégiques
nous avons déjà conduit pas mal
d'auditions sur le sujet mais il nous
importe vraiment d'avoir votre regard
sur cette sur cette gestion des stocks
et puis cette logique budgétaire est ce
que vous n'avez pas le sentiment que
toutes les eaux les économies faites
dans les années précédentes nous les
payons aujourd'hui beaucoup plus cher et
puis j'aurai une deuxième question vous
avez évoqué la nécessité d'une autorité
de l'état qu'ils soient transversale
quel est alors également avec votre
expérience de président de région qu'il
est votre regard sur le les échanges qui
ont eu lieu entre le pilotage à la fois
rs et préfecture et puis vous avez
évoqué quand même une nécessaire
articulation entre la médecine de ville
et l'hôpital articulations qui n'a pas
existé pendant la gestion de cette crise
j'aimerais aussi recueillir votre avis
sur cet équilibre
merci merci ce que je voulais bien je
vais commencer par vos derniers points
de façon à ce que la mémoire soit soit
la plus fraîche possible l'articulation
rs préfecture honnêtement je le dire
pudiquement le moins qu'on puisse dire
c'est que c'est perfectible pas la
réalité c'est que ça n'a pas marché
comme ça aurait du marché
je n'ai pas eu à mettre en place les ars
j'ai eu l'habitude en ce qui me concerne
de fonctionner avec les a et rage quand
j'étais ministre cette réforme qui était
portée je n'était plus ministre
j'étais membre du gouvernement j'en
était solidaire j'ai eu à travailler que
les ars
mais moi il y avait un problème dans
cette réforme ces comptes et possède le
préfet de prérogatives en la matière
pour moi il devrait y avoir un
représentant de l'état et je vais même
plus loin
geci même que le monde de l'éducation
nationale ne peut pas ne peut pas être
géré dans les régions dans les
départements dans les académies s'en
rendre compte aux préfets pour moi le
représentant de l'état dans un
territoire c'est le préfet préfet de
département sous préfet de région et les
préfets de département mais au niveau
notamment d'une académie d'un rectorat
le correspondance c'est le préfet de
région et ensuite son équipe les préfets
de département mais pour moi la base de
tout c'est le préfet et la préfectorale
quelque chose qui tient dans ce pays est
quelque chose qui à sens de l'état mais
aussi l' approche terrain on n'a pas
beaucoup d'opérateurs de l'état comme ça
donc dans ces cas là on les a faiblit
pas en et l'argent en leur enlevant des
prérogatives
on les renforce on les renforce ça
correspond plus à la vision que j'ai je
suis bien évidemment fervent partisan de
la décentralisation et de la
déconcentration ça a du sens aussi ça a
du sens aussi donc que toute cette
partie sanitaire soient enlevées au
préfet et ça nous a amené à avoir une
sorte de double commande
alors je vais être très franc avec vous
j'ai eu la chance dans ma région d'avoir
un écosystème assez particulier avec un
directeur général d'à des rays qui
avaient aussi une expérience des rouages
de l'état il avait été directeur de
cabinet du ministre ait pu un préfet de
région j'espère que je parle
compromettre qui est tout simplement
exceptionnel et nous avons eu un
véritable dialogue
les autres alors peut-être aussi qu'en
temps que son siège de santé attention
ancien ministre de la santé je les ai
souvent dit dans les médias il ya qu un
ministre de la santé en exercice et
c'était olivier vers en chemise la
sentais pas joué au ministre de la santé
même chez moi dans ma région je suis
resté dans ma logique de
i dans deux régions de près mais on a eu
un dialogue on a eu un dialogue qui nous
a évité je penchais nous il ya aussi les
parlementaires des autres france qui
sont là d'avoir une guerre de tranchées
entre le public et le privé
il est vrai coopération j'ai vu moi
saint quentin pour l'accès aux urgences
de la clinique elle était là au tout
début
avant l'arrivée des passions qu vide
vous savez ou dans la cour de l'hôpital
dans la cour d urgence pour justement
travailler ensemble on a eu tout un
travail notamment avec des acteurs comme
sos médecins et les médecins libéraux
tant qu'ils ont pu pratiquer donc sur
tous ces sujets là on a eu la chance
dans la région parce que vous l'avez
rappelé tout à l'heure nous sommes la
région qui était la première touchée
premier cluster est chez nous nous avons
ensuite connu moins de rome que bien
évidemment l'ile-de-france que grotesque
d'autre que d'autres régions mais nous
avons été les premiers touchés
et je ne vous cache pas que je craignais
le pire et on a vraiment essayé
d'anticiper au maximum
moi même c'était pas mon rôle je suis
venu parfois à l'improviste dans des
cellules de crise dans certains hôpitaux
et de ensuite de passer des messages de
me faire le relais pas mon rôle pas
forcément pour a pour habitude de
traverser dans les clous mais mais
toujours est il que j'estimais que
c'était mon rôle sans prendre la place
de qui que ce soit vous voyez il ya eu
ce dialogue permanent et très vite nous
avons obtenu dans la région qu'il y ait
une réunion bi hebdomadaire le lundi et
le jeudi une conférence stratégique
zonal préfet les cinq préfet de
département 5 rétais département la rs
les présidents de départements
le président de région les présidents
des associations des maires et bien
évidemment les représentants de l'état
pour expliquer la situation que nous
puissions nous faire remonter un certain
nombre de points et pour y apporter des
solutions
donc deux fois par semaine ensuite on
est passé à un rythme hebdomadaire
et là ça a été relancée depuis déjà
quelques semaines dès le mois de
septembre dans la région de façon à ce
qu on se parlait à ce qu'on se comprenne
mais on n'aurait pas eu ce dialogue
commun est vraiment efficace entre est à
rs à qui on s'adresse à qui on s'adresse
moi j'avais un cadre pour pouvoir le
faire mais si c'est pas le cas ici
s'étaient pas entendus bien évidemment
vous savez comment ça se passe de
pilotes pas de pilote
c'est ça le fond du problème dans
l'organisation des mois je plaide
pour que tout ce qu'ils soient sécurité
sanitaire soit à nouveau placée sous
l'autorité de l'état
je pense que dans les conclusions de la
commission denquête y aura certainement
tout un pan sur ce retour d'expérience
et qu'est-ce qu'il faut proposer
pardonnez moi comme évolution du rôle
des agences régionales de santé lors
l'enjeu de la commission n'est pas de
parler des seules agences régionales de
santé mais c'était le cas ce serait avec
plaisir que je reviendrai devant vous
que j'ai contribuerait parce que ça fait
partie des sujets sur lequel je
réfléchis et ce travail est d'ailleurs
même des directeurs généraux des agences
régionales de santé ont des idées en la
matière mais le système actuel dans une
crise comme celle ci ne fonctionne pas
comme il devrait comme ils devraient
comme il devrait fonctionner sur la
question de en quelque sorte quelle
autorité transversale
il y a un bon exemple vous savez le
modèle américain c'est vraiment pas mon
modèle pour plein de raisons
mais il ya un modèle qui est intéressant
en terme de sécurité des personnes
c'est la fema la fema les initiales ça
veut dire fédéral fédéral agency
management et e aimé emergency federal
emergency management agency
voilà c'est une agence qui existe
d'ailleurs quand je m'étais rendu aux
états unis pour pour faire le plan ainsi
qu'en asie on avait regardé ce qui
fonctionnait bien et il y avait il y
avec la fema tout un organisme qui est
transversal et qui permet à la fois de
prendre des décisions et d'assurer aussi
toute cette partie logistique
c'est un eprus plus nous on a fait
brusquement en france mais là ils ont
fait eprus plus d'envoyer et là par
contre ça bouscule est vraiment beaucoup
de choses pour le mettre en place même
avec le soutien bienveillant du
président chirac c'était compliqué mais
toujours est il qu'on a quand même mis
en place les prusse mais la fema
américaine franchement c'est à regarder
un parce que c'est quelque chose une
opérationnalité les l'opérationnel
remarquable et c'est une véritable une
véritable agence encore une fois
efficace c'est ce type d'organisation de
structure qu'il aurait fallu faire c'est
à dire aller au delà même de la logique
de l'eprus en lui donnant une vision
encore plus transversale et pas
seulement lié ou reliés à la santé bon
après ça n'est pas non plus l'enjeu
aujourd'hui mais on voit bien que sur la
sécurité des pères
notamment sur les questions de sécurité
civile et sanitaire
j'espère qu'après tout ce qui s'est
passé on va en tirer des enseignements
parce que comme vous l'avez indiqué tout
à l'heure il s'agit pas de se dire on
attend tout de l'état c'est qu'on n'a
pas à amener les français à avoir
vraiment les clés pour la prévention et
sur un certain nombre de dossiers
c'est vrai sur ces questions sanitaires
c'est vrai sur ces questions épidémique
mais on pourrait parler également de
tous les accidents de la vie courante
tous ces accidents laa la france est un
pays dans lequel une ville un peu plus
importante que ma ville de saint-quentin
disparaît chaque année nous avons
soixante mille disparition liées à des
accidents de la vie courante
principalement en france et la
prévention permettrait la
responsabilisation permettrait
clairement d'éviter un tel drame drame
dont on ne parle quasiment jamais je
reviens à votre question la logique
court termisme il faut bien le voir cela
fait des années et des années que nous
sommes confrontés à des équations
budgétaire particulièrement difficile
non particulièrement douloureuse voilà
depuis bien longtemps
moi même en 2004 quand je rentre au
gouvernement c'est pour mener la réforme
de l'assurance maladie
vous savez tout cela et c'est pas
nouveau et puis nous avons aussi un
autre sujet en france c'est la toute
puissance de bercy alors on pourrait
faire tout un débat sur bercy
les fonctionnaires de bercy vous disent
qu'ils sont là aussi d'une certaine
façon pour pour tenir la baraque pour
faire en sorte qu' on puisse rêver les
sciences sauf que derrière il ya une
vision quasiment court termiste parce
que année après un exercice budgétaire
par exercice budgétaire plf et plfss
il faut que ça rentre il faut que ça
tienne et ce sont des visions pour
permis dès que vous avez des dépenses en
plus qui présentent un caractère
exceptionnel
ça vient bousculer les fameuses
équilibre financier
donc il faut soit des circonstances
exceptionnelles quoi qu'il en coûte
soit il faut qu'il y ait un défi à
relever préparer le pays par rapport au
risque pandémique soit avoir un soutien
quand vous vous retournez du président
de la république lui-même voire du
premier ministre pour pouvoir faire or
j'ai bénéficié
j'ai bénéficié d'une certaine façon de
cet écosystème là nous avions à préparer
le pays
face à ce risque aviaire qui était
papier terrifiant sur les conditions de
létalité un président de la république
pour qu'il est question de santé c'est
pas une question comme les autres
rapports de jacques chirac avec tout ce
qui est charnelle humains médical n'est
plus à démontrer et donc il ya eu à
différents moments des passes d'armes
avec le budget mais j'ai toujours gagné
par votre talent grâce à chirac est donc
derrière ça a permis très chaude or à
partir du moment où vous sortez de
président et nicolas sarkozy a été dans
la même logique parce que il a vu avec
h1n1 les risques que ça présente l
anticipation c'est aussi son truc
mais à partir du moment où vous avez pas
tout le monde qui se met en ligne qui
l'emportent bercy par rapport à quoi par
rapport à ségur un ministère de la santé
qui n'a pas forcément le même poids
politique
vous avez des conseillers budgétaire de
bercy dans chaque ministère n'est pas
des conseillers du ministère de la santé
à bercy non mais c'est comme ça que ça
c'est comme ça que ça se passe
et c'est cette logique qu'au court
termiste qui l'emportait mais d'une
certaine façon chassez le naturel il
revient au galop
j'ai eu la chance de pouvoir mettre 100
places roselyne bachelot à disposer des
moyens nécessaires pour faire face a
h1n1 mais rappelez vous je crois qu'il
ya plus personne qui était à l'époque
mais les débats des commissions
parlementaires assemblée et sénat sont
mémorables
on lui a reproché effectivement d'avoir
pas beaucoup dépensé trop dépenser d'en
avoir trop fait sa marque et aussi les
esprits et la question qui s'est posée
c'est est-ce que du coup il fallait pas
un peu réduire la voilure et ça je pense
que ça imprégner les esprits je pense
que ça a beaucoup un prix et ce prix
donc une logique budgétaire parce que
l'argent n'est pas si facile que ça
trouver une logique court termiste
passons les exercices les uns après les
autres et moi je plaide pour qu'il y ait
une loi pluriannuelle sur tout ce qui
est sécurité sécurité sanitaire et qui
soit véritablement sanctuarisés et puis
ensuite la loi votée c'est bien respect
de la loi c'est bien
j'avais fait inscrire une disposition
qui disait que chaque année chaque année
le ministre de la santé ou son
représentant doit veiller à
l'inscription dans le budget des crédits
absolument nécessaire au renouvellement
des stocks de masques
c'est la loi comment ça s'est passé
ensuite
c'est toute la question mais si je peux
me permettre c'est aussi la question du
contrôle que nous exerçons sur mille et
une choses mais sur des sujets comme ça
je pense que c'est quelque chose
d'absolument indispensable et après vous
avez aussi un dernier aspect sur lequel
je reviens parce que l'importance pas de
jeter la pierre et autres même si je ne
suis dupe de rien l'important c'est
d'essayer de voir comment on évite que
de telles choses ne se reproduisent et
après il ya la place du ministère de la
santé le ministère de la santé c'est un
ministère au combien important pour nos
concitoyens
mais que ce soit dans les hiérarchies
gouvernementales dans les priorités
politiques à n'est pas forcément
toujours le cas et quand nous avons eu à
préparer en ayant carte blanche de la
part de dominique de villepin et de
jacques chirac tout le plan la mise en
place de l'eprus ça a fait tousser et
notamment je le dis on a travaillé de
façon partenariale avec le sgdn mais à
notre départ je pense que certains
étaient contents de dire que maintenant
le sgdn allait reprendre toute sa place
et jouer un rôle transversal parce que
si vous avez une crise sanitaire
la santé gère mais la santé gère jusqu'à
un certain moment ensuite c'est
l'intérieur qui prend la main
donc vous voyez nous étions allés
certainement au delà de ce qu'elle rôle
traditionnel de la santé au delà des
disponibilités budgétaires qui sont
celles de la santé et après certainement
fallait il revenir à une certaine norme
à une certaine non et tout ça qui est à
prendre en compte et ensuite le fait que
l'eprus et son indépendance je pense que
la maison ségur
regardez ça aussi d'un oeil pas si
bienveillant que ça ait l'occasion
justement de réintégrer l'eprus est
toujours dans la même logique
excusez moi mais voyez c'est pas
seulement le budgétaire s'est pas
seulement court termisme c'est une
logique qui est une logique systémique
m'était très éloigné d'une seule chose
l'efficience
merci bernard jomier merci monsieur le
président merci monsieur le ministre
donc moi mes questions vont être
focalisé on va dire sur votre ancienne
fonction n'est pas sur vos fonctions
actuelles de deux présidents de région
mais plus sur le regard que vous avez en
tant qu'ancien ministre
donc j'ai quatre sujets je voudrais
aborder avec vous que vous en êtes vous
avez déjà abordé le premier c'est la
gouvernance en santé publique dont dont
vous avez parlé de sa confrontation à
l'équation budgétaire mais dans dents
sur la question de la gouvernance en
santé publique
on est quand même marqué par le fait que
notre pays a à une forme on va dire de
sous investissement sûr dans la question
qui est très ancien qui il a fallu
attendre tout de même 2016 pour que
commence à émerger une agence nationale
de santé publique
elle est toujours en émergence on a le
sentiment que le processus n'est n'est
pas achevé et cette question là nous
paraît enfin paraître tout de même
fondamental dans la capacité qu'un pays
à avoir une culture de santé publique et
donc être en capacité de répondre
rapidement
quand une question comme une épidémie
mais ça pourrait être d'une autre nature
se pose de façon aussi brutale et donc
vous avez tenu beaucoup de propos donc
là ce matin cette question vous en aviez
vous aviez développer votre pensée
lors de vos auditions à l'assemblée
nationale et je voudrais que vous vous
alliez plus loin sur cette cette
revendication du côté régalien de la
réponse en santé publique parce que et
ça fait le lien avec une deuxième
question vous avait effleuré aussi on a
vu dans cette crise que l'efficacité
était bien souvent dans la réponse
territoriales mais que l'égalité qu'on
doit à nos concitoyens
devant toute situation et tout risque
elle ne peut pas être uniquement dans la
réponse territoriale et qu'elle se joue
bien au niveau de l'état et donc la
conjugale et la conjugaison de cette
efficacité
et de cette égalité républicaine
actuellement ne trouvent pas de réponses
satisfaisantes dans ce cas était la
réponse à l'épidémie donc quels sont vos
quels sont vos vos réflexions à ce sujet
et est ce que est ce que quel constat
faites-vous et que comment voyez vous
les choses et puis pour terminer de
façon générale sur cette question de la
gouvernance
vous avez y compris donc à l'assemblée
nationale lors de votre audition et puis
très rapidement ici mais évoquer la
question de ce ce que j'appelle un peu
le couple conseil de défense et dsn qui
est secrétaire général de la défense et
la sécurité nationale maintenant clg dsn
c'est plus le sgdn et donc comment
comment après c'est clairement le
conseil de défense et est présenté comme
le lieu où ce pilote l'épidémie une
ancienne ministre de la santé nous a dit
un petit peu crûment bon c'est surtout
une réunion pour que le chef de l'état
puisse assister aux réunions
j'aurais voulu savoir comment vous vous
évaluez ce mode de pilotage et ce et son
articulation avec une politique de santé
publique
et puis j'aurai deux questions très très
précise donc la question budgétaire je
n'y reviens pas mais je voudrais très
clairement lorsque vous étiez ministre
est ce qu'il ya des décisions de
sécurité sanitaire qui ont été remises
en cause par le ministère du budget
parce que on brandit sans arrêt la
question budgétaire on peut la brandir
dans tous les domaines de notre vie
publique
mais bon voilà une fois qu'on a dit ça
après on en revient à l'équilibré des
comptes publics l'endettement de la
france
et quand les textes arrive au parlement
dans les chambres du parlement les voix
ne manque pas pour dire qu'il faut faire
des économies donc est-ce que très
concrètement vous avez des décisions qui
ont été mises en cause par le ministère
du budget de sécurité sanitaire non
enfin dernière merci donc on la réponse
donc donc ce n'est pas si problématique
que ça probablement vous avez compris ma
question c'est que ya probablement bien
autre chose que de toujours invoquer
l'argument budgétaire il ya probablement
mais vous y reviendrez la place qu'à la
santé simplement dans notre gouvernance
et dans l'échelle on va dire de notre
administration de notre personnel
politique etc
mais je vous laisserai répondre si je
fais pas les questions les réponses
comme même si parfois vous pouvez en
avoir le sentiment
dernière question vous auriez été
ministres en octobre 2018
est ce que vous estimez a aussi ses il
faut que sortir des généralités il faut
être clair
est ce que vous estimez que votre
directeur général de la santé aurait dû
vous informer de ce qui est quasiment un
changement de doctrine en tout cas une
décision lourde de conséquences sur les
masques ou est-ce que vous estimez que
c'était du ressort du directeur général
de la santé merci on commence par la
quatrième
oui ils auraient dû mais si je ne me
trompe pas il aurait l'otan plus du
qu'il était l'auteur d'une note quelques
années auparavant qui était
particulièrement alarmiste j'ai répondu
à votre question d'accord bien sûr la
troisième je voulais dit tout à l'heure
est-ce que sur les questions budgétaires
j'ai renoncé à des opérations non mais
je voulais dit aussi un alignement de
planètes peut être quasi exceptionnel
préparation h5n1 président de la
république qui a totalement conscience
de ce qu'il faut faire et qui dit tu
fais au mieux tu fais au mieux comme ça
que prochaine et jacques chirac est
derrière également un premier ministre
très convaincu que ces questions de
santé très important d'ailleurs j'aurais
tout son soutien quand je réussir à
mettre en place l'interdiction de fumer
dans les lieux publics dominique de
villepin était comme ça toutes les
questions de santé
il n'y avait pas forcément le même
rapport que jacques chirac mais c'était
aussi quelque chose de très de très
important et donc tout le monde était
aligné parce qu'il y avait cette
préparation est d'ailleurs vous
remarquerez on a reproché aux
gouvernements successifs d'enfer
oh mais pas d'en faire trop peu parce
qu'il n'y avait pas de moyens on n'a
jamais manqué de masse qu'on n'a jamais
manqué de matériel on n'a jamais manqué
le doze de doses vaccinales en la
matière par contre on aurait même pu
avoir la remarque parce que on a des
procédés notamment ou rappelés sur la
question du tamiflu tamiflu parce qu'il
y avait deux médicaments pour la grippe
aviaire le tamiflu
je me suis moi même rendu en suisse
rencontrer le pdg de roche pour obtenir
des commandes de tamiflu et comme ils
étaient coincés ils ne pouvaient pas
tout nous livrer en termes de
médicaments de gélules on a obtenu fages
a obtenu 2 qu'il puisse nous livrer en
vrac et c'est la pharmacie des armées
s'est adapté de façon remarquable qui
faisaient la transformation justement du
tamiflu il ya un autre médicament le
relenza avec glaxo qui justement le
produisait donc voyez il a fallu aussi
sortir de la seule orthodoxie notre
système on est capable notre système en
est capable mais il faut rechercher
encore une fois l'efficacité
à quelles conditions pour vous il en est
capable
la question des volontariats
volontariste sauf que bon c'est pas
traverser dans les clous fois je pense
aujourd'hui toi sont quand vous faites
de la politique en traversant dans les
clous c'est fini la cie ont bousculé pas
les choses de façon si vous respectez
uniquement les conventions je ne vis pas
de faire n'importe quoi mais la question
c'est si on respecte uniquement les
convenances et d'ailleurs on le voit
bien regarder sur la sphère des masques
on a pu les commander rapidement et tout
ça parce que on a été capable de
bousculer l'ordre des choses sauf qu'on
se donne le sentiment c'est qu'en france
on est capable de bousculer l'ordre des
choses seulement quand on est au coeur
de la crise aussi le faire pour éviter
la crise
c'est ça aussi le rôle de l'anticipation
après vous me disais autre conseil de
défense excusez ma le conseil de défense
et ce qui est en train de remplacer le
conseil des ministres en ce moment c'est
ça ouais d'accord c'est bien ça car il
ya un outil d'évolution la
constitutionnel ou politique je vais pas
en dire plus mais enfin ça donne le
sentiment que le conseil des ministres
n'est plus là que c'est maintenant le
haut conseil de défense qui décide de
tout donc vous avez compris mon point de
vue c'est que et des institutions il ya
des instances
les respecter c'est bien non pardon
c'est mieux c'est mieux sur la question
de la gouvernance sur la question du
rôle de l'état
vous voyez sur les différents stades
jusqu'où jusqu'où le ministère de la
santé est compétent à partir de quand
vous passer le relais au ministère de
l'intérieur qui est certainement mieux
staff et parce que il ya également des
questions d'ordre public à la question
de la préfectorale
le monde de la santé il est là pour
organiser les soins mais un moment donné
on rentre sur une logique sociétale et
c'est normal que ce soit le ministre de
l'intérieur qui pilote le tout donc les
différents stades
justement dans une épidémie ensuite que
ce soit l'eprus ensuite que ce soit la
question de la réserve sanitaire c'est
l'état
cette gouvernance là c'est forcément
l'état il ya une déclinaison
territoriale et là je pense que ce sont
les préfets qui sont les mieux armés
pour organiser cette opérationnalité
territoriales mais tout ça c'est l'état
et ensuite que l'on voit comment on ne
se réfugie pas derrière l'état va tout
faire du coup on attend c'est par contre
d'avoir cette articulation avec les
autres acteurs et notamment les acteurs
médicaux mais aussi les acteurs
territoriaux
mais l'ossature c'est clairement c'est
clairement comme ça que ça se passe
juste un point je n'oublie de vous le
dire tout à l'heure j'ai dû renoncer à
rien mais clairement l'eprus bercy était
contraint bercy était contre mais on a
quand même créé l'eprus grâce aux
soutiens dont je parlais et l'eprus
sociaux on va dire aussi pourquoi bercy
était content c'est que ça nous
permettait d'éviter la question des
plafonds d'emplois
on ne pouvait recruter du personnel pour
avoir cette opérationnalité échos
recrute 1 or on ne pouvait pas que les
plafonds d'emplois en faisant l'eprus on
pouvait y déroger c'est pour ça que
mercier des contres mais n'ont pas pu
nous empêcher
et la transformation de santé publique
france votre avis par rapport à la
question de bernard jomier l'eprus
inclus dans annonce déjà dit c'est une
erreur c'est clairement une erreur il y
avait une spécificité de l'eprus de
toute façon il faut aussi faire
attention à vouloir tout noyé dans des
organisations très grands noms pense
qu'on peut faire des économies d'échelle
mais si sur les questions des fonctions
support peu vous organiser différemment
mais quand vous vous remettez en cause
vous nier la spécificité de tel ou tel
acteur faut pas s'étonner que ce soit
comme dirait l'autre noyés dans la masse
merci d'ailleurs j'avais aux mamans du
médiator tentation j'aurai beaucoup
parlé notamment dans cette enceinte avec
nombre de parlementaires pour créer une
agence qui regrouperait vraiment tout et
certains en ont dissuadés en montrant
justement qu'on risquait de perdre un
certain nombre de spécificités
merci bernard jamais souhaité non c'est
bon et bien écoutez merci monsieur
munissent pour les questions nous allons
groupe est maintenant les questions de
nos collègues je vous demanderais d'être
peut-être précis concis dans les
réponses également monsieur le ministre
il est 10 heures nous avons encore une
demi heure consacrée aux questions si
nous voulons obtenir l'emploi du temps
alors jean françois rapin
oui monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre
j'avais plusieurs questions mais vous y
avez répondu dans les questions des
rapporteurs globalement je saisi au bond
ce que vous avez dit sur la vaccination
saisonnière de la grippe en particulier
pensez vous et je vous dois peut-être
d'aller plus loin dans la démarche d'une
vaccination beaucoup plus importante
peut-être que celle d'habituel mans que
l'on devrait peut-être reprendre le
schéma qui avait été adoptée sur la
grippe h1n1 en 2009 d'une vaccination
collective prévoyant une pandémie et
quand je dis collective c'est même
international ce serait à la fois
peut-être important de pouvoir le
réaliser au plan sanitaire bien sûr pour
les raisons que vous avez évoquées mais
je pense que ça pourrait être une
répétition aussi d'une future
grande vaccination contrôle couronne et
viège merci jean françois husson est ce
que je peux ça se fait pas en groupe les
questions que je comprenais pas pour
bien comprendre le sens de la question
du sénateur a pas je sais que ça ne se
fait pas d'interpeller et dans votre
esprit monsieur le sénateur ça serait
obligatoire ou pas oui merci jean
françois lussier on va répondre
précisément là oui merci merci monsieur
le président monsieur le ministre nous
sommes aujourd'hui je crois
engagé dans une politique préventive
contre le virus nous portons des masques
elle nous limitons les rassemblements il
ya les gestes barrière gens passent même
s'il y eut des atermoiements en tant
qu'ancien ministre de la santé
quelles sont les failles que vous avez
pu constater dans la politique de
prévention en matière de santé que vous
avez pu mener et quelle faille
identifiée vous aujourd'hui et si
possible si vous en êtes en capacité au
regard de vos fonctions actuelles
qu'elles seraient les évolutions
possibles pour demain deuxième question
vous avez beaucoup insisté sur la place
des territoires dans la mise en oeuvre
de la politique sanitaire
en fait vous avez été clair vous avez
affirmer la prééminence de l'état
notamment dans la sécurité sanitaire
mais sur la politique sanitaire
j'ai compris que les territoires les
collectivités devaient être je dirais
qu'on pourrait aujourd'hui avoir une
politique beaucoup mieux articuler pour
être efficiente
est-ce que vous pouvez préciser quels
sont les collectivités qui pour vous
sont au coeur du dispositif pour le
rendre efficace efficient merci olivier
neau merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre
en vous écoutant et puis tout au long de
ces auditions on a tout de même le
sentiment que l'état à baisser la garde
sur cette question de la pandémie alors
est ce que c'est pour des raisons on l'a
déjà évoqué mais accidentelle
conjoncturel budgétaire structurel mais
aussi tout simplement est ce qu'on n'a
pas sous-estimer le le risque de
pandémie et moi c'est le sentiment que
j'avais eue après les auditions du début
de cette année première question et
deuxième question aviez vous des
échanges lorsque vous étiez ministre
c'est une question qui m'est chère avec
les homologues européens et est ce que
une politique européenne de la santé
fait sens et qu'elle pourrait être son
périmètre
notamment parce qu'à partir du moment où
il ya schengen et des échanges on le
voit bien les difficultés
transfrontalière quand on est dans un
secteur transfrontalier
voilà quel pourrait être le périmètre de
cette politique européenne de la santé
je remercie merci olivier paccaud si
michel présidente chez le ministre dans
vos premières réponses à catherine de
roche vous avez insisté sur la mission
régalienne protectrice de l'état
vous avez aussi insisté sur le rôle des
collectivités est effectivement dans les
hauts de france que ce soit la région
que ce soit les départements ou les
communes elles ont eu un rôle essentiel
je veux prendre un seul exemple quand
même qui est important est qu'on ne cite
jamais on a parlé des masses qui ont été
distribués mais moi ce qui m'a frappé
dans beaucoup de communes c'est l'aide
qui a été apportée notamment aux
personnes âgées isolées mais qui va
rester chez elles pour qu'elles puissent
être fournis en aliments on a fait leurs
courses pour eux et souvent ce sont des
élus qui se sont mis au travail vous
avez insisté sur la notion de retour
d'expérience d'évaluation le mot retour
d'expérience devait prononcer pro 4 fois
effectivement il faut tirer des leçons
dans nos auditions nous avons notamment
eu les ambassadeurs de corée du sud et
de taïwan qui sont deux états qui ont su
tirer des leçons des diverses pandémie
qu'il avait eu à affronter et qui ont
mis en place des plans très précis qui
ont fait que encore et là il ya eu 350
morts en taiwan ya eu moins de dix morts
ma question elle reprend un petit peu
elle approfondit celle de mon ami jean
françois husson
concernant le rôle que doivent que
peuvent jouer les collectivités dans un
plan de lutte contre une
pandémie contre un incendie
épidémiologique
comment les impliquer on ne peut pas
faire sans elle elles sont bien sûr il
ya le préfet vous avez insisté sur le
rôle du préfet mais les collectivités
parce qu'elles sont au plus proche
jusqu'à la petite commune ont un rôle à
jouer
ma question parce que je sais que vous
connaissez bien les collectivités de
france sait comment inclure les diverses
collectivités dans le plan de lutte face
à une pandémie
merci victoire jasmin
oui merci monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre vous avez évidemment parler
de les pousser des actions que vous avez
menées notamment concernant la dengue le
chikungunya qui concerne
particulièrement les autres maires à
l'époque où vous étiez là vous aviez
déplacés et je crois que c'est ce sont
les premières fois où l'eprus s'est
déplacé justement vers nos territoires
particulièrement voix de lou on parle et
le collègue précède on vient de parler
de l'implication des collectivités
évidemment pour ce type de crise les
collectivités doivent être en première
ligne étant donné que pour la prévention
ce sont les collectivités que ce soit
pour la dengue le chikungunya sur les
moustiques et les islanders qu'il faut
éliminer
alors je voudrais compte tenu de ce que
vous avez déjà dit de votre capacité à
réajusté en fonction des plans pour vous
donne surtout quand ils sont sur le
papier que vous payez la possibilité si
vous le souhaitez avec le recul est le
vôtre de comparer votre façon de réagir
avec les différents territoires
d'outre-mer au moment où vous étiez là
et aujourd'hui par rapport à cette
pandémie est là est-ce que vous avez des
quelques conseils parce que nous sommes
encore dedans il ya un rebond alors si
vous avez un certain nombre d'éléments
je vous remercie de pouvoir nous les
donner je remercie michel meunier le
président anselmi vous nous avez parlé
de logique sanitaire systémique et je
suis bien d'accord mais avouez que dans
ce système il ya quand même bien des
absents ou en tout cas je veux parler
des médecins généralistes des médecins
de ville qui sont très peu sollicités
ont été très peu sollicité et le sont
maintenant tardivement alors quand vous
étiez ministre de la santé vous aviez
fais en sorte que ce soit au centre des
préoccupations sanitaires et plusieurs
actions que vous avez menées mais tu es
bien les médecins libéraux dans le
système
entre 2006 et 2020 à votre avis qu'est
ce qui s'est passé pour qu'on en soit là
et pour que au cours des auditions que
nous menons ce soit tout un secteur qui
est était encore une fois très peu
associés à la gestion de cette crise
sanitaire
merci et enfin angèle préville merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre
alors je vais évoquer avec vous la
problématique des personnes âgées
puisque ce sont les personnes âgées qui
ont payé un lourd tribut à cette
pandémie jusqu'à présent donc vous avez
insisté effectivement sur la fonction
régalienne et protectrice de l'état est
ce que vous estimez que nous avons
suffisamment protégé des personnes âgées
en france
un professeur que nous avons auditionné
la semaine dernière me répondait sur
cette même question que lorsque je
faisais la comparaison avec l'allemagne
avec quatre fois moins de décès en
allemagne concernant les mêmes personnes
âgées qu'en allemagne avait une priorité
absolue alors en quoi nous n'avons pas
de priorité absolue est ce que vous
voyez des solutions qui nous
permettraient d'améliorer et de faire en
sorte que nous protègerons mieux les
personnes âgées en france
merci mais jean sol à une dernière
question monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre vous avez vous nous avez dit
tout à l'heure que nous n'avions pas de
culture de l'évaluation en france je
suis tout à fait d'accord
ne pensez vous pas que c'est que cette
culture de l'évaluation pourra évoluer
évolué en sortant d'une culture des
contraintes par la certification et des
normes notamment qui qui tombe sur les
épaules de nos professionnels de santé
mais pas que
merci donc une salle veut importante de
question monsieur le ministre que j'ai
été amené à regrouper puisque le temps
est contre un mais il reste encore le
temps nécessaire pour répondre à toutes
ces questions et aux quatre remarques
départ que de départ merci non ce
n'était pas le nombre c'est toujours que
j'ai peur quand il y a beaucoup de
questions à la suite de perdre le fil et
de ne pas répondre précisément aux
questions posées c'était juste ça
m'arrange je compte sur vous jean
françois rapin
je ne pense pas qu'il faille rendre la
vaccination obligatoire
déjà très compliqué aujourd'hui très
compliqué la vaccination
on voit qu'il y a de plus en plus de
réticences sur la question du vaccin
si l'on décidé de la rendre obligatoire
je pense qu'on aurait une bonne part de
l'effet inverse
je continue à croire à l'incitation à
une pédagogie non infantilisante non
infantilisante pour justement montrer
quel est l'intérêt est de montrer
notamment vis-à-vis de ses proches qu'il
ne pourra il ne devrait pas y avoir de
confusion entre les symptômes d'une
grippe 20 contre la grippe saisonnière
est justement là qu vide c'est ça c'est
d'expliquer c'est ici qu'il faut se
soigner
d'accord mais qu'il faut se faire
vacciner pour éviter cette confusion
c'est ça le véritable enjeu est je pense
que le gouvernement doit penser mais ces
spots la très pédago doivent être mis en
place très rapidement on sait que la
campagne vaccinale doit commencer mi
octobre
dans quelles proportions c'est prévu les
les vaccins arrivent quand de la part de
qui comment tout ça va se passer
les médecins libéraux sont déjà dans la
boucle les établissements tout ça c'est
ça qui est vraiment très important mais
encore une fois il ya aussi autre chose
je dis ce que je pensais de la façon
dont la sphère des masques avait été
traitée gérer si je peux dire la
question des vaccins
rien n'est simple rien n'est simple la
question des tests aujourd'hui mais sur
les vaccins le vaccin qu'ovide là je
parle du vaccin qu'ovide là on n'a pas
le droit de se louper un parce que
l'épidémie l'épidémie il y aura une fin
de l'épidémie qu'au moment où il y aura
un traitement
et le traitement c'est le vaccin même
pour ce vaccin là je suis pas pour le
rendre obligatoire mais il faut inciter
donner envie expliqué et donc sur toutes
ces crises sont là avant qu'il y ait le
vaccin on nous dit 2021 à quel moment
par mois qui peut le dire les
laboratoires pharmaceutiques comme le
dira 1 on est un grand pays
donc on doit être servi en premier
surtout qu'on a des labos
pharmaceutiques sur notre territoire
on doit être servi en premier mais
l'appareil la logistique de la
vaccination
la préparation de cette étape est aussi
on va le dire clairement sur
l'organisation des ministères faut déjà
qu'il y ait des équipes qui soit
aujourd'hui sur la question des tests
mais d'autres équipes qu'ils soient déjà
dans la prospective et de l'anticipation
sur la question du vaccin et c'est ça
qui est important
et donc je redis très clairement
vaccination obligatoire dans le pays
dans lequel on est 1 réaction des
français face aux soins et face au
vaccin
je pense qu'on n'arrivera pas à obtenir
les résultats je pense qu'on n'arrivera
pas à obtenir les risques d'un monsieur
le ministre mais jean françois rapin
disait également organisé une
vaccination collective un peu comme ça
avait été fait du temps de la chan a
alors qu'il y avait eu adapté mais est
ce que serait le moment le s'entraîner
quoi avec le vaccin dès cette année de
la grippe quoi voilà l'inscription dans
ces conditions là et je n'ai pas la
réponse
combien de doses de vaccins grippaux ont
été commandés parce que s'ils ont décidé
de faire sénateur a pas ça veut donc
dire qu'on a les doses suffisantes et là
je n'ai pas au moment où je parle moi
les éléments pour savoir combien de
doses ont été commandées auprès de qui
et à quel moment la disponibilité juste
sur le vaccin
je pense que la grande différence entre
l'allemagne et vaccination qu'on avait
eu en 2009 et la vaccination grippale
telle qu'elle est entendue aujourd'hui
c'est qu'on a aujourd'hui de l'unido
seringue bruyant vaccination grippale
alors qu'à shayna on avait des doses des
doses en flacon voilà donc est ce qu'on
est capable aujourd'hui de reproduire la
même chose
et toute la question c'est combien ont
été commandés et justement à quel moment
la disponibilité pour répondre à jean
françois husson sur la question
notamment de l'articulation on a
beaucoup entendu l'état parlait de
l'articulation maire préfet ça semble
évident ça semble évident le maire qui
va la commune qui est la cellule de base
la démocratie mais je pense qu'il ya
d'autres niveaux de collectivités qui
peuvent aussi apporter leur concours
et si on parle de la continuité de
l'état ya la dimension sanitaire mais il
ya aussi une dimension économique et
sociale
olivier paccaud le disais tout à l'heure
sur la dimension sociale
les élus quels qu'ils soient ont apporté
un concours remarquable le rôle des
maires a été saluée mais toutes celles
et ceux qui sont bénévoles m'engager
pour les distribuer des repas faire des
courses avec est toujours un système 1
en france 1 c'est toujours le système d
mais qu'est-ce qui tient ses les
français même quand parfois on se dit
est ce que l'état assume bien sa mission
les français tiennent toujours et on
peut remonter à n'importe quelle période
de l'histoire les liens humains
c'est ce qui fait la différence entre ce
pays et les autres et puis à tous ceux
qui n'y tient trois communes en france
malheureusement qu'il y avait aussi des
élus qui sont des bénévoles de la
république et qui sont engagés comme ça
il des associatifs il ya eu des voisins
il ya eu des parents il y avait aussi
des élus et les élus on ne souligne pas
eux quand ils sortaient de chez eux
parce qu'il fallait aller dépanner
il avait aussi peur de ramener ce satané
virus à la maison en revenant donc c'est
ça aussi ça n'a pas été suffisamment mis
en avant met en valeur alors vous allez
me dire qu'ils ont l'habitude de ça
enfin on peut aussi quand même souligner
le rôle est montré qu'en cas de crise
heureusement qu'ils sont là
heureusement qu'il soit donc je crois
que l'articulation peut se faire au
travers des compétences existantes
aujourd'hui mais il faut qu'on soit
considérée comme des partenaires
genevois notamment dans les départements
comme l'oise qui est un département en
première ligne les ehpad ça concerne
aussi le conseil départemental qui avait
besoin d'information qui avait besoin
d'informations or on a parfois le
sentiment que l'accès à l'information
même ça c'est compliqué comment on
pouvait dire vous êtes dans un
département que vous ne savez pas
exactement comment ça se passe dans les
ehpad et que vous ne pouvez pas porter
non plus tout le concours nécessaire et
conseillers départementaux d'autres
départements ici
c'est quelque chose qui joue tout le
problème mais c'est pas seulement dans
le cadre d'une crise est ce que les
collectivités locales sont vraiment
considérés comme des partenaires à part
entière pas des empêcheurs de tourner en
rond pas des gens qui font pour gêner
mais des gens qui veulent aussi protégé
et 6 est organisée dans les plans et je
pense que dans les plans stratégiques
que nous aurons à mettre en place dans
les mois dans les années qui viennent il
faut davantage intégrer l'ensemble des
niveaux de collectivités locales vous
voulez justement établir des règles
sanitaires dans les collèges
c'est bien d'en parler avec les
départements quand même plutôt que
d'apprendre dernier maman est de voir la
notice qui sera fait
la date de réouverture des classes
on a eu des dialogues parfois qu'on
était un petit peu musclé parce que je
voulais tout simplement qu'on puisse
s'organiser que ce soit pas le bazar
voyez des sujets comme ça faut juste
qu'on soient considérés comme des
partenaires à part entière il fallu
parfois que je prenne mon téléphone et
je disais aux ministres moi je veux bien
faire le maximum mais je veux tout
simplement éviter que ce soit le bazar
parce que le problème tout est compliqué
dans une gestion de crise mais un peu
d'anticipation quoi mais il faut nous
considérer vraiment excusez moi je ne
redoute pas je répète vraiment comme des
partenaires comme des partenaires à part
entière
on a une insuffisance de protection pour
des raisons x ou y que vous serez plus à
même et plus qualifiés que moi pour
définir pour déterminer à la fin de vos
auditions mais il faut bien voir que
quelles que soient par temps calme ou
par tempête
les gens veulent être protégés j'ai pas
les assistés ils veulent être protégés
et c'est la mission première de l'état
ça a été la question des masques au
départ et aussi des équipements et là où
il faudra qu'on revienne dessus sur le
retour d'expérience encore aujourd'hui
encore aujourd'hui au centre hospitalier
un centre hospitalier dans le
département du pas de calais yens
autiste qui étaient envoyés indiquant
qu'il fallait faire attention à la
consommation de gants de gand parce que
il n'y avait pas la disponibilité
nécessaire donc j'ai fait remonter le
sujet hier auprès du préfet et auprès de
la rs ça arrive ça arrive
sauf que ça fait déjà quelques semaines
que j'avais alerté sur ces questions là
sur ces questions là encore une fois
pourquoi j'ai alerté je vois plus malin
qu'un autre mais j'ai toujours mes
oreilles qui traînent et j'essaye aussi
de faire en sorte constitué à portée des
gens
parce qu'il ya la question des masques
rappelez-vous aussi la question des
blues et tout le reste
et ça on doit se doter de stocks
stratégiques suffisants pour pouvoir
apporter la réponse à ce que la même si
elles système d le système d qui était
se servir de sacs poubelles honnêtement
personne n'a envie de revendiquer sa
donc sur la question de la protection
c'est clair parce qu'on a parlé
justement du curare et autres des
médicaments liés à l'arrêt à mais c'est
aussi tous les éléments les surblouse
les blues les gants les visières et tout
cela donc sur cette question
d'insuffisance de protection ça tient
également la question de stocks
stratégiques et pas seulement pour les
masques et pas seulement sur sur les
masques et je voulais dit tout à l'heure
c'est la question de la culture de la
confiance qui pour moi est véritablement
la clé de tout olivier henno l'état
baisser la garde oui y'a pas que nous en
france à d'autres pays vous savez des
pays qui s'en sont vraiment très bien
sorti je ne sais pas si on peut le dire
mais ils ont connu aussi les frayeurs
taiwan c'est vrai la corée du sud c'est
vrai également on nous donne beaucoup en
exemple l'allemagne mais il ya aussi eu
des difficultés avec l'allemagne mais ça
tient aussi à leur système est
intéressant c'est à dire que leurs
systèmes industriels a permis aussi de
s'adapter très vite on a mobilisé
l'industrie pour par exemple les
respirateurs moi ce que je ne vois pas
c'est pourquoi on n'a pas mobilisé
davantage également l'industrie sur la
confection de masse heureusement qu'on a
eu le système d avec des couturières
improvisé des couturières professionnel
je le vois chez moi on a lancé toute une
filière avec les masques résilience
toyota à valeo ont arrêté de produire
son il est obligé d'arrêter de produire
1000 on fait des matches il ya eu ce
système d'e mails organisé ça nous
aurait permis de répondre encore plus
plus plus rapidement et ce qui manque
c'est la culture de la prévention et du
risque on est comme ça en france on est
comme ça en france c'est à dire que nous
nous réagissons mais la culture de
l'anticipation
c'est ainsi fait que ça n'a pas toujours
était allé dans l'adn des décideurs pas
seulement politique mais aussi mais
aussi public alors s'est souvent moqué
le mendiant aimez vous parce que vous
étiez un assureur
j'entends dire depuis quelques jours à
nouveau chaque assureur avec un côté un
peu péjoratif c'est dommage c'est un
très beau métier mais l'assureur doit
aussi prévoir le pire et garantir le
pire
françois husson qui vous dira inverse
mais chaîne m6 music en grèce 10 minutes
anticiper et prévenir c'est quelque
chose de clés sur la question de la
politique européenne sur la coopération
et notamment sur la recherche sur le
vaccin ne pas se marcher sur les pieds
en revanche si on parle notamment de
l'accès aux frontières et autres là on
reste dans la dimension régalienne
en revanche l'accès aux frontières de
l'europe ça a du sens et à chaque fois
oui européen mais plus largement mes
homologues en chine j'ai demandé à
rencontrer le ministre de la santé aux
états unis j'ai rencontré également le
secrétaire à la santé
parce que vous le savez c'est ainsi fait
qu en politique vous pouvez reprendre
les bonnes idées des autres y a pas
droit d'auteur à payer
surtout quand ça fait du bien la
population ça fait du bien dans un pays
donc il faut pas hésiter à voir ce qui
s'est fait ailleurs comme il me reste 45
secondes je vais répondre ah je répondre
à tout le monde
olivier paccaud a raison ça fait partie
des missions régaliennes on dit toujours
le régalien c'est la sécurité la justice
la défense le respect de la laïcité mais
dans ces cas là il ya la sécurité et je
pense pour ma part que l'éducation et
santé font aussi partie de ses priorités
de ses priorités régaliennes j'ai parlé
d est pas tout à l'heure en le disant le
lien social on l'a fait et là il faut
clairement que l'on puisse voir les
choses l'articulation avec les
collectivités non seulement elle est
indispensable mais elle se fait dans
certains secteurs il faut l'étendre
quand vous avez notamment un risque
nucléaire ou un problème nucléaire qui
est chargé de la distribution des pass
idiote ce sont les collectivités sur
place donc on s'est fermé donc pourquoi
on le prévoit dans certains domaines et
pas dans d'autres je pense qu'il faut
tout remettre à plat
peut-être ce sera une l'une de vos de
vos missions
pour madame et sénatrices jasmin sur la
question de l'état et collectivités
locales
j'ai essayé justement dit dire d'y
répondre pour vous dire que prenons la
démoustication
il ya une priorité qui est donnée par
l'état parce que je me souviens être
allé également dans l'ain dans les alpes
maritimes après chikungunya pour dire
justement que ce que l'on avait connue à
la réunion pour commencer pouvez aussi
arrivée sur le territoire métropolitain
tout le monde me dit c'est pas possible
il ya ce rôle là mais quels sont les
acteurs c'est bien évidemment les
collectivités locales
il faut clairement dire qui
fait quoi définition par l'état
articulation avec les avec les
collectifs les collectivités mais sur la
question de l'anticipation c'est ce que
j'ai indiqué à l'instant c'est la
question du vaccin qui maintenant pour
moi et le sujet devant nous les tests
bien évidemment ce n'est pas réglé le
gouvernement a pris des décisions là
dernièrement mais c'est la question de
l'anticipation maintenant sur le vaccin
qu'ovide qui pour moi est la clé de tout
et là on n'a pas le droit de se louper
on n'a pas le droit de se louper michel
magne et sur la question des médecins
généralistes on m'a trop reproché
pendant mes différentes fonctions de
m'appuyer sur les médecins généralistes
a pas ce que c'est les médecins de
famille ce qu'ils on a confiance et
notre système de santé vous le savez
c'est ainsi fait et et beaucoup tourné
autour des défis de l'hôpital de
l'hôpital public des besoins de
l'hôpital public
mais comment on peut faire sans les
médecins et je pense que personne ne
souhaite qu'il y ait une deuxième vague
du même niveau
mais là il faudra davantage s'appuyer
sur les établissements privés
bien sûr mais aussi sur les médecins qui
ne demandaient que cela
maintenant c'est parce que je voulais
regarder madame la sénatrice j'en suis
j'en suis j'en suis désolé madame pribyl
me disais sur la question des anciens
bien sûr qu'ils ont été insuffisamment
protégé mais excusez moi c'est pas tout
à fait nouveau 2003 la canicule
j'ai eu à gérer moi l'épisode de
canicule en 2006 et on a pu mesurer les
progrès qui avait été fait mais ça tient
aussi au regard d'une société depuis
combien de temps une réforme de la
dépendance on en parle très bien et
qu'elle n'est toujours pas abouti je
pense que la solidité et l'honneur d'une
société c'est l'attention qu'elle porte
à l'aube de la vie au crépuscule de la
vie on en est assez loin aujourd'hui
et la question qui se pose c'est comment
elles sont placées stratégiquement dans
les priorités de l'état et ensuite
pardonnez moi mais on en revient quand
même à ça c'est la question des moyens
et des moyens humains parce qu'au bout
d'un moment tous les grands discours se
fracassait dessus quand les gens n'ont
pas le temps de pouvoir s'occuper
dignement des personnes âgées
c'est cette question là qui était posé
sur la question de de jean sol je pense
qu'il ya aussi le rôle des commissions
parlementaires pour justement s'assurer
de tous ceux de ce suivi c'est le
contrôle à proprement parler du
gouvernement et sur ces questions
notamment certification et autres je
pense que là il ya l'état qui cette
crise n'est pas passée sera aussi
forcément mobilisés sur d'autres choses
et là encore une fois j'ai été
parlementaire j'ai adoré ses fonctions
de parlementaire je pense que là la
fonction de contrôle pas de censeur pas
de critique mais de contrôle pour
améliorer les choses légitime totalement
le rôle d'une commission d'une
commission comme comme la vôtre et vous
voyez c'est ce qui m'intéresse et pour
vous répondre aussi monsieur le monsieur
le président tout à l'heure quand vous
le camp quand vous le disiez
on a essayé à un moment donné je ne suis
dupe de rien de me faire porter le
chapeau du changement de doctrine et de
stratégie je ne suis dupe de rien j'ai
beaucoup de défauts mais je ne suis pas
naïf commission denquête à l'assemblée
m'a permis justement de rétablir la
vérité les vérités ce que je voudrais
dire jours à exonérer personne de ses
responsabilités mais quand j'ai quitté
mes fonctions
ça n'est pas le ministère de la santé
n'ont plus ni la ministre de la santé
qui a voulu changer la doctrine n'aucune
façon j'aurai l'occasion de répondre
avant le 7 octobre aux questions écrites
que vous m'avez posé pour certaines ce
sera plus compliqué parce qu'il faudra
que je demande aux archives nationales
parce que certains documents je n'étais
pas conservé conservez moi même mais il
faut voir comme vous le disiez madame la
rapporteure tout à l'heure contre une
culture du risque et de l'anticipation
qui n'a pas toujours été votre marque de
fabrique loin s'en faut en france et pas
seulement dans ce domaine là quand vous
voyez les logique budgétaire
quand vous voyez les logique systémique
vous comprenez pourquoi on en est arrivé
là
et si vous n'avez pas soit des
professeurs de rennes bricaire rajoute
aussi à sa façon à l'époque quand il
fait ce rapport
quand vous avez pas aussi des acteurs
publics politique qui prenne ce dossier
à bras le corps il ya beaucoup de choses
qui reprennent le dessus et au final on
n'est pas préparé et l'état n'assure pas
sa mission première qui est celle de de
protéger les gens en 2013 le sgdn prend
cette décision et l'a fait avaliser sur
le changement de doctrine c'est pas un
ministre qui prend ses décisions il n'y
a aucun ministre à qui vous pouvez faire
endosser cette responsabilité de dire
faut faire des économies les gens seront
moins protégés et qu'ils signent en bas
ça n'existe pas on peut penser ce qu'on
veut des politiques quand on se lève le
matin on cherche plutôt à bien faire
kamal faire est plutôt à protéger les
gens donc c'est bien ça il faut aussi
s'extraire de toutes ces contingences
pour bien voir quel est le coeur de
notre de notre de notre mission est la
question qui est posée c'est la question
des consignes claires monsieur le
président je pense qu'il nous faut
rompre avec cette tradition où nous
sommes en matière de sécurité civile de
sécurité sanitaire à nous dire l'état
fait hélas je ne voudrais pas que ça
devienne le chacun pour soi mais qu'on
voit mieux comment l'état se prépare
anticipe et protège et qu'elle est là
art qui est demandé à chacun
collectivités locales comme individu des
pays savent le faire des pays savent le
faire le japon notamment sait le faire
sur un certain nombre de risques et je
pense notamment à des risques de
tremblement de terre où nous il nous
faut maintenant l'envisager sous toutes
ses formes par rapport à la panoplie des
risques qui peuvent exister mais ce
qu'il faut bien comprendre c'est que
quand des décisions ont été prises et je
pense notamment sur la question des
masses que vous l'avez aussi évoqué avec
le gnl en 2013 regarder ce que nous
portons les uns et les autres se sont
pas des masques ffp2 certains peuvent
avoir du mal à les supporter le
changement de doctrine dont il est
question du haut conseil c'est pas pour
diminuer le nombre de masse et pour
savoir ce qui est le plus adapté aux uns
et aux autres et on a fait une confusion
terrible entre les millions de masques
ffp2 et les masques chirurgicaux
on m'avait dit qu'on n'en avais trop
fait parce qu'à l'époque nous avions
prévu également des masques pour les
caissières les routiers les forces de
sécurité ou autre
et au final il n'y avait pas 600
millions de masques il y en avait 1
milliard 400 millions et ce qui est
intéressant parce que je l' ai vu qui
était évoquée dans le questionnaire que
vous m'avez transmis c'est que au final
les capacités de production dont nous
avions voulu nous doter pour nous mettre
à l'abri de la dépendance vis-à-vis des
chinois le ministre de la santé chinois
vous avez lu mon audition à l'assemblée
m'avait dit vous savez nous on en
produit beaucoup pour vous on vous les
vents mais si on à l'épidémie en même
temps que vous vous passerez après me le
reprocher pas et me dit vous feriez
exactement la même chose et il avait
raison
c'était pour avoir cette autonomie
regardé comme on a la mémoire courte
la grande distribution est venu voir
tous les productions locaux nationaux et
vous nous en fournissent et vous nous en
fournissent et et puis dès qu'on est
revenu avec l'idée la première vague
était derrière nos parent n'a repris d
habitude d'acheter moins cher
on a acheté en asie donc la question
même au delà de la question de la baisse
de production il ya une préférence
nationale ou pas parce que en plus nous
racontons pas d'histoires la grande
distribution pas elle est battue par les
règles des marchés publics
elle peut acheter aussi un peu plus cher
et donc vous avez des fabricants qui se
sont engagés et qui du coup se retrouve
avec des stocks l'aï aussi une
responsabilité de l'état pour pouvoir
dire de façon récurrente
voilà grosso modo les stocks dont
nous aurons besoin épidémies ou pas
parce que ne nous y trompons pas les
pics de pollution nous pourrons
connaître dans certaines grandes
métropoles feront que notre rapport aux
masses que va changer et qu on les
portera et qu'il y aura dans chaque
maison des masques qui seront sur la
commode ou qui seront dans la voiture
dans la boîte à gants on aura maintenant
ce réflexe là moi même j'ai voulu
initier une opération un masque pour
tous dans la région pour faire une
première dotation pour tout le monde
parce que je vais aussi le souligner la
sphère des masques on peut en parler
commodément mais quand vous avez des
masques qui coûtent 30 centimes à 50
centimes l'unité et des familles pour
qui ça pose aucun problème mais des
familles nombreuses
ça commence à représenter un certain
coût et même les masque en tissu ne sont
pas des masques éternelle donc voilà
pourquoi sur toutes ces questions parce
que je pense que ça correspond également
à la logique à la logique de protection
qui est celle de l'état
ça n'empêche pas la responsabilisation
des citoyens mais là il va falloir qu'on
change vraiment vraiment de culture tout
à fait et ma question c'est est un petit
peu plus précisément 6,7 cette stratégie
de 'stock collective s'en est en voie de
protection leur notamment d'achats
canada avec les kits de protection en
avait pas en fait était contreproductive
par rapport à votre volonté affichée de
responsabilisation de nos concitoyens et
est ce que la conclusion qu'on pourrait
en tirer ou ne pas en tirer serait de
del de territorialiser les les stocks
plutôt que rester des sur des stocks
nationaliser les lits des mâles est en
droit de se poser la question dans cette
fameuse doctrine qui a été fait c'était
sur la question des stocks stratégiques
et des stocks tactique et là je l'assumé
c'était une bonne idée pour avoir une
disponibilité plus rapide mais si je
peux me permettre
dans ce qui a été fait à l'époque les
masques étaient pas concerner les
masques reste est du ressort du national
parce que c'était stratégique 7 et
stratégiques le vrai changement le vrai
changement c'est qu'en 2013 il est dit
que chaque employeur doit assurer les
masses mais la question qui se pose à la
main sénatrice c'est qu'il employeurs
des médecins libéraux
et c'est comme ça qu'ils se sont
retrouvés où on ne leur a pas dit qu'il
devait en avant il avait un petit stock
or certains avaient même sénateur
rappelle ahmad de certains qui avaient
récupéré les stocks de ce que j'avais
envoyé en 2007 c'était périmé depuis
longtemps bien évidemment mais l'idée de
cette dotation que je fais en tant que
ministre de la santé à l'époque pour
transmettre aux professionnels c'est
d'avoir un premier kit d'une certaine
façon d'urgence d'urgence
et c'est là c'est qu'encore une fois il
ya un changement de doctrine mais on
s'assure pas la doctrine va être
respectée on dit des employeurs donc il
ya des établissements qui avait c'était
au titre des migac c'était bien
évidemment pas dans la tarification
c'était au titre des migac mais les
masques ne figure pas dans la liste
complète de ce qu'il ya dans les postes
sanitaires mobiles et dans ce qu'il ya
dans cette doctrine
il n'ya pas les masques donc c'est pas à
l'époque on dit une différence entre
stocks stratégiques et tactiques c'est
pour être opérationnel et il n'ya pas
les masques mais en 2013 le sgdn dit
maintenant c'est des employeurs qui
payent très bien qui a effectué le
contrôle et les questions que nous
sommes posés ce que disait l'académie de
médecine en disant on peut supposer
qu'une instruction circulaire
interministérielle indiqué aux
professionnels de santé libéraux aux
chefs des établissements de santé et aux
responsables d'établissements qui leur
incombe et ceux dotés de masques ffp2
pour la protection des professionnels
susceptibles effectivement d'être est
d'être exposés et ça confirme un certain
nombre prendre des décisions que nous
avons eu me semble-t-il déjà obtenu
prendre des décisions c'est bien
s'assurer de leur exécution c'est bien
aussi écouter s'il n'y a plus d'autres
questions je mets fin à l'audition merci
d'avoir pris le temps nécessaire et un
parti à cette audition
merci nous allons reprendre dans
quelques instants chers collègues
voilà pour cette audition de xavier
bertrand devant la commission d' enquête
du sénat sur la gestion de la crise du
corona virus xavier bertrand qui a été
auditionné en tant que président de la
région haute france également en tant
qu'ancien ministre de la santé
entre 2005 et 2007 et entre 2010 et 2012
alors les sénateurs l'ont interrogé sur
l'impréparation de la france de l'état
pour faire face à une telle épidémie de
coronavirus et pour xavier bertrand
cela s'explique par la dépendance de
l'état à une logique budgétaire à une
logique d'économie à une logique de
court termisme
je vous propose d'écouter l'un des
moments forts de cette audition de
xavier bertrand la logique court
termisme
il faut bien le voir cela fait des
années et des années que nous sommes
confrontés à des équations budgétaire
particulièrement difficile non
particulièrement douloureuse voilà
depuis bien longtemps
moi même en 2004 quand je rentre au
gouvernement c'est pour mener la réforme
de l'assurance maladie
vous savez tout cela et c'est pas
nouveau et puis nous avons aussi un
autre sujet en france c'est la toute
puissance de bercy alors on pourrait
faire tout un débat sur sur bercy
les fonctionnaires de bercy vous disent
qu'ils sont là aussi d'une certaine
façon pour pour tenir la baraque pour
faire en sorte que l'on puisse régler
sur sauf que derrière il ya une vision
quasiment court termiste parce que année
après un exercice budgétaire par
exercice budgétaire plf et plfss
il faut que ça rentre il faut que ça
tienne et ce sont des visions courte est
remis dès que vous avez des dépenses en
plus qui présentent un caractère
exceptionnel
ça vient bousculer les fameuses
équilibre financier
donc il faut soit des circonstances
exceptionnelles quoi qu'il en coûte
soit il faut qu'il y ait un défi à
relever préparer le pays par rapport au
risque pandémique soit avoir un soutien
quand vous vous retournez du président
de la république lui-même voire du
premier ministre pour pouvoir faire or
j'ai bénéficié d'une certaine façon de
cet écosystème là nous avions à préparer
le pays
face à ce risque aviaire qui était
papier terrifiant sur les conditions de
létalité
un président de la république pour qu'il
est question de santé c'est pas une
question comme les autres rapports de
jacques chirac avec tout ce qui est
charnelle humains médical n'est plus à
démontrer et donc il ya eu à différents
moments des passes d'armes avec le
budget mais j'ai toujours gagné
papa vos talents grâce à chirac est donc
derrière ça a permis de faire les choses
or à partir du moment où vous sortez de
président et nicolas sarkozy a été dans
la même logique parce que il a vu avec
h1n1 les risques que ça représentait l
anticipation c'est aussi son truc
mais à partir du moment où vous avez pas
tout le monde qui se met en ligne qui
l'emportent
vers 6 par rapport à quoi par rapport à
ségur un ministère de la santé qui n'a
pas forcément le même poids politique
vous avez des conseillers budgétaire de
bercy dans chaque ministère n'est pas
des conseillers du ministère de la santé
à bercy non mais c'est comme ça que ça
c'est comme ça que ça se passe
et c'est cette logique qu'au court
termiste qui l'emportait mais d'une
certaine façon chassez le naturel il
revient au galop
j'ai eu la chance de pouvoir mettre 100
places roselyne bachelot à disposer des
moyens nécessaires pour faire face a
h1n1 mais rappelez vous je crois qu'il
ya plus personne qui était à l'époque
mais les débats des commissions
parlementaires assemblée et sénat sont
mémorables
on lui a reproché effectivement d'avoir
pas beaucoup dépensé trop dépenser d'en
avoir trop fait sa marque et aussi les
esprits et la question qui s'est posée
c'est est-ce que du coup il fallait pas
un peu réduire la voilure et ça je pense
que ça imprégner les esprits je pense
que ça a beaucoup appris et ce prix donc
une logique budgétaire parce que
l'argent n'est pas si facile que ça
trouver une logique court termiste
passons les exercices d un prêt les
autres et moi je plaide pour qu'il y ait
une loi pluriannuelle sur tout ce qui
est sécurité sécurité sanitaire et qui
soit véritablement sanctuarisés et puis
ensuite la loi votée c'est bien respect
de la loi c'est bien j'avais fait
inscrire une disposition qui disait que
chaque année chaque année
le ministre de la santé ou son
représentant doit veiller à
l'inscription dans le budget des crédits
absolument nécessaire au renouvellement
des stocks de masques
c'est la loi
comment ça s'est passé ensuite c'est
toute la question
mais si je peux me permettre c'est aussi
la question du contrôle que nous
exerçons sur mille et une choses mais
sur des sujets comme ça je pense que
c'est quelque chose d'absolument
indispensable et après vous avez aussi
un dernier aspect sur lequel je reviens
parce que l'importance pas de jeter la
pierre et autres même si je ne suis dupe
de rien l'important c'est d'essayer de
voir comment on évite que de telles
choses ne se reproduisent et après il ya
la place du ministère de la santé le
ministère de la santé c'est un ministère
au combien important pour nos
concitoyens
mais que ce soit dans les hiérarchies
gouvernementales dans les priorités
politiques à n'être pas forcément
toujours le cas et quand nous avons eu à
préparer en ayant carte blanche de la
part de dominique de villepin et de
jacques chirac tout le plan la mise en
place de l'eprus ça a fait tousser et
notamment je le dis on a travaillé de
façon partenariale avec le sgdn
mais à notre départ je pense que
certains étaient contents de dire que
maintenant le sgdn allait reprendre
toute sa place et jouer un rôle
transversal parce que si vous avez une
crise sanitaire
la santé gère mais la santé gère jusqu'à
un certain moment ensuite c'est
l'intérieur qui prend la main
donc vous voyez nous étions allés
certainement au delà de ce qu'elle rôle
traditionnel de la santé au delà des
disponibilités budgétaires qui sont
celles de la santé et après certainement
fallait-il revenir à une certaine norme
à une certaine norme et tout ça qui est
à prendre en compte et ensuite le fait
que l'eprus et son indépendance je pense
que la maison ségur regardez ça aussi
d'un oeil pas si bienveillant que ça ait
l'occasion justement de réintégrer
l'eprus est toujours dans la même
logique
excusez moi mais voyez c'est pas
seulement le budgétaire s'est pas
seulement le court termisme
c'est une logique qui est une logique
systémique mais qui est très éloigné
d'une seule chose
l'efficience voilà pour cette audition
de xavier bertrand devant la commission
d' enquête du sénat sur la gestion de la
crise du coronavirus commission denquête
qui poursuit ses travaux ce matin et je
vous propose de voir une table ronde sur
les aspects numérique 2
la crise sanitaire comment les nouvelles
technologies ont permis de lutter contre
les piles les contre l'épidémie je vous
laisse écouter cette audition heures et
ensuite des questions groupe et venant
de nos commissaires alors sans plus
tarder vous rappeler que tout et manage
mensonge est susceptible d'une peine
d'amendé allant jusqu'à 75 mille euros
une peine de prison pouvant aller jusque
5 années et je vais vous demander de
prêter serment de dire la vérité toute
la vérité de lever la main droite et de
dire je le jure
bruno sportisse je le jure à la cour et
madame blanc madame dinis je vous
remercie et je passe la parole
lenaria la cnam après l' inverse comme
on le souhaite aller allez-y monsieur
sportys mesdames et messieurs les
parlementaires donc merci de me donner
l'opportunité de préciser quelques
éléments en introduction je tiens
d'abord à resituer l'action d'inria
l'institut national des sciences et
technologies du numérique dans le cadre
d'une d'un ensemble plus vaste d'action
de lutte contre le coc vide 19 dès le 20
mars de nombreuses équipes
inria de manière spontanée et où et à la
demande de la direction se sont engagés
auprès de collègues hospitaliers auprès
d'établissements hospitaliers pour une
utilisation plus forte des outils
numériques dans le cadre de la gestion
de la crise dès le 20 mars nous avons
mis en place une mission inria qu'ovide
19 pour soutenir ses projets
d'ingénierie numérique de projets de
recherche court terme et plus de 35
projets ont été initiés dans ce cadre
sur la base d'un autofinancement de
l'institut et je tiens à saluer à cette
occasion l'engagement exceptionnel de
tous les chercheurs les ingénieurs les
fonctions d'appui qui ont répondu
présent en parallèle dès la fin du mois
de mars nous avons été impliqués dans un
consortium européen notamment auprès de
l'allemagne
un consortium de r&d pour étudier le
développement possible d'applications
mobiles d'exposition aux risques
et le 8 avril une lettre mission du
premier ministre a précisé une mission
confiée à inria sous la supervision du
secrétariat d'état au numérique afin de
mettre en place un consortium public
privé pour développer une telle
application d'abord sous la forme d'un
prototype en amont de toute décision
politique de déploiement éventuel notre
travail avec nos partenaires allemands
dans le cadre du consortium que j'ai
déjà cité nous avait permis de
recommander une certaine classe de
systèmes pour des applications de ce
type dit centralisée pour trois raisons
principales la première raison était la
garantie du respect de la vie privée et
des données de santé clé pour l'adoption
d'une telle application
la deuxième raison était la garantie de
la cybersécurité et la troisième raison
était la nécessité qu'une autorité de
santé devait avoir la main pleine et
entière sur le système pour gérer au
mieux la crise sanitaire dans le cadre
d'une stratégie globale
la maîtrise s'entend par la maîtrise des
paramètres de l'application la maîtrise
de son développement est tout simplement
la connaissance de ces de son impact et
ce choix nous a conduit à ne pas vouloir
utiliser le système développé par apple
et google puisque de notre analyse
il ne répondait pas à ces trois
exigences respect de la vie privée
cybersécurité maîtrise par l'autorité de
santé et pour autant nous avons mené
plusieurs cycles de discussions avec les
propriétaires des systèmes
d'exploitation le 18 avril nous avons
dévoilé la première version d'un
protocole de transmission des données
appelé robert développé conjointement
par une équipe française
inria et par une équipe de la frane
hours the shaft allemande afin de
répondre à ce cadrage de respect de la
vie privée de cybersécurité de maîtrise
par l'autorité de santé le 26 avril nous
avons rendu public un consortium public
privé construit en moins de deux
semaines pour mener à bien le
développement d'un prototype d'un
système fondé sur ce protocole aux côtés
d'inria dans son rôle de coordinateur
d'acteurs publics comme l'inserm santé
publique france ou l'ansi l'agencé
nationale de sécurité des systèmes
d'information
entreprise privée au nombre de cinq
capgemini dassault systèmes lui nabi
studio orangé wings se sont engagés via
un cadre contractuel simplifiée pour
développer pro bono publico un tel
prototype
je tiens à préciser que le développement
de ce système n'a donné lieu à aucun
financement spécifique d'aucune sorte
que cela soit pour les acteurs publics
ou les acteurs privés et que l'on estime
à plus de 150 personnes
les personnes mobilisées pour le
développement de cette application sans
compter le concours des forces armées de
la ratp pour des campagnes de tests le
coût total estimé de ce développement
est de 2,5 millions d'euros
le 9 mai nous avons dévoilé un nouveau
protocole une version alternative du
protocole robert le protocole désiré
afin de mettre sur la table un candidat
possible pour l'interopérabilité au
niveau européen en alternative aux
standards de fait développé par apple et
google
une preuve de concept de ce protocole a
été développée partager avec nos
partenaires européens début juillet dans
le cadre d'un groupe d'experts numérique
et santé le réseauiq network sous
l'égide de l'union européenne et notre
volonté de trouver une solution
européenne souveraine a été également
illustrée par le lancement mi mai d'une
action de standardisation notamment à
travers l'action d'orange au sein de
l'institut de standardisation des
télécommunications européen là-dessus
en parallèle d'un cycle de développement
extrêmement courts de moins de six
semaines de mi-avril à fin mai nous
avons mené plusieurs phases de test dans
particulier des tests terrain fin mai
avec trois jours de campagne sur le site
inria d'euros concours avec le concours
des forces de l'armée je l'évoqué est
une soirée deux compagnes dans des rames
de la ratp avec le concours de la ratp
et le 2 juin après une décision
politique de passer au déploiement la
première version de ce top cow vite a
été déployée de manière opérationnelle
je tiens à souligner que mener
l'ensemble des actions énuméré en moins
de six semaines est inédit dans le monde
numérique et je tiens à rendre hommage
là aussi à l'engagement exceptionnel de
toutes les personnes impliquées dans le
projet j'ai un regret dans cette période
c'est de ne pas avoir réussi à
contribuer à installer les conditions
on d'un dialogue science technology
société pleinement serein pour à la fois
sortir de la naïveté des fantasmes sur
le numérique un grand enseignement pour
l'avenir et que notre responsabilité
d'instituts de recherche et de porter
des actions majeures en ce sens alors à
partir du 2 juin
une dernière phrase de conclusion si
vous permettez la conclusion je vous
permets à partir du 2 juin bien notre
action a été encadrée par un accord
cadre avec la direction générale de la
santé pour accompagner le la mise en
exploitation de l'application stop
coville inria agissant comme assistant à
maîtrise d'oeuvre et je voudrais juste
terminée en témoignant de l'importance
de mon analyse que la france est plus
mener et continuer à mener continuer à
mener un projet de ce type d'abord parce
qu'à ma connaissance nous sommes le seul
pays européen à avoir mené un projet de
r&d de bout en bout ce qui est un gage
d'autonomie stratégique dans le cadre de
gestion de pandémie futur
deuxièmement parce que le déploiement
d'un tel prototype conduit à un vrai
retour d'expérience qui permet de faire
évoluer et d'améliorer le système et
enfin parce que le système déployé et
pleinement sous contrôle de notre
société démocratique comme l'ont montré
notamment les interventions de la cnil
est maîtrisée par notre autorité de
santé ce n'est pas une boîte noire qui
pesait dans un secteur sensible les
données de santé
à l'heure où plusieurs grands acteurs
technologiques lancent une activité dans
l'assurance santé
voilà je vous remercie de votre
attention merci madame khoury 10h46 à
l'isie de me passer la parole pour
préciser le rôle de l'assurance maladie
dans la stratégie des pistes et racé
isolé fixé par le gouvernement pendant
la crise qu vide donc l'assurance
maladie s'est vu confier une nouvelle
finalité un d'action pendant la crise
puisqu'elle s'est vu confier la
responsabilité de participer à l'action
de tracing de la population et dans 7
cas de ce cadre de cette nouvelle
finalité qui lui a été confiée à la
développer l'outil qui s'appelle contact
au vide
qui permet de réaliser cette action
donc peut-être pour vous re précise et
l'articulation entre les différents
systèmes d'information qui ont été
développés la partie dépistage c'est à
dire le recueil de l'ensemble des
résultats de tests
ça c'est un outil qui s'appelle si dette
et ça ça a été développé par le
ministère de la santé
la direction générale de la santé avec
comme sous traitants l'ap-hp donc ce
système d'information il vise à
recueillir les résultats de l'ensemble
des tests il est rempli par les
laboratoires et c'est là qu'on sait où
en sont ou seront colligées l'ensemble
des données nécessaires pour savoir
identifier les gens qui ont des tests
positifs
donc ça c'est nous this side est
colligées l'ensemble des résultats des
tests nous ont fait le tracking
donc on a un outil qui s'appelle contact
qu'ovide qui vise à identifier les
personnes qui sont positives et surtout
à identifier leurs contacts puisque
derrière il faut qu'on appelle les
personnes contacts et il faut qu'on les
informe qu'elle son contact que
quelqu'un les arts reconnaît les avoir
avoir eu un contact rapproché avec elle
au moment où étaient potentiellement
contre elle étaient potentiellement
contagieuse et donc nous il faut qu'on
appelle ses contacts pour les prévenir
et pour que derrière ils se fassent
dépister qu'il me porte bien sûr des
masques et qu'il s'isole puisque ils
sont susceptibles d'avoir été
contaminées
donc nous on a développé cet outil
contact qu'ovide qui vise à tracer
alors comment ça s'articule entre 6
dette est l'outil contact co lead en
fait compte tenu du tempo dans lequel on
a dû travailler n'a pas été possible
d'interconnecter au moment où on a créé
ces outils complètement ces deux outils
donc en gros
l'assurance maladie chaque jour regarde
les résultats de six depp et on sait ce
qu'on vérifie si nancy dès qu'il ya des
gens qui sont testés positifs et qui ne
figure pas dans notre outil à nous qui
s'appelle contact qu'ovide et s'il ya
quelqu'un qui est positif dans 6 des
pesquies figure pas dans notre outil
contacts qu vide au bout d'un certain
temps 24 heures maximum
on rappelle la personne
pour pour entend enclencher le tracing
le l'outil contact qu'ovide là je vous
ai parlé du rôle de l'assurance maladie
n'est pas utilisée uniquement par
l'assurance maladie parce que vous savez
que dans la politique de dépistage
traçage isolement bien sûr le rôle des
médecins est essentielle les médecins
participent de l'opération de traçage et
donc les médecins lorsque ils reçoivent
un patient et qu'il a des symptômes qui
pensent qu'il est potentiellement
porteur du coc vide eux-mêmes engage
utilisent notre petit contact qu'ovide
pour commencer les opérations de traçage
et qu'on puisse derrière recenser les
cas contacts et nous derrière on va
rappeler les quatre pattes pour vérifier
que on a bien toutes les informations
pour être sûrs qu'ils sont bien informés
sur le fait qu'il doive se dépister qui
doivent porter des masques qui doivent
être isolées donc peut-être juste pour
préciser ces points avant d'aller plus
loin mais donc nous on est responsable
de l'outil contact qu'ovide et cidep
donc la partie car enseigner par les
laboratoires ça ça relève du ministère
néanmoins bien sûr on a travaillé
étroitement quand on a conçu le
dispositif et on a accès aux résultats
de cidep justement pour éviter que des
gens diagnostiqués positifs ne soit pas
un tracé que ça tarde à sortir peut-être
qu'à ce niveau là je m'arrête de déjà là
me blanc oui peut-être qu'on s'arrête
classés
très bien fait une fois pas de souci là
important c'est effectivement que nous
puissions avoir un certain nombre
d'éclairages est donc je commence par
sylvie verdier pour les questions de nos
rapporteur ensuite bernard jomier puis
catherine des roches
merci monsieur le président première
question à monsieur sportys donc vous
avez retracer l'élaboration de ce top
cow vide
j'aimerais que vous caractérise y ait un
peu le l'utilisation et l'efficience de
stock co vide donc est-ce que vous
pouvez nous dire à ce jour combien on
recense d'utilisateurs de ce top cow
vide
et puis combien de notification sur le
risque de contamination ont été envoyés
à des utilisateurs de ce top cow vide
par ailleurs au cours de l'audition que
nous avons eues avec madame la maire de
paris anne hidalgo il a déploré que
toutes les informations qui étaient
relatives aux clusters dans les systèmes
d'information n'est pas été transmis aux
élus locaux
j'aimerais ça j'aimerais avoir votre
votre retour là dessus et est ce que on
envisage de faire évoluer le système
pour remédier à cela et puis bien
entendu vous avez dit monsieur sportif
tout à l'heure que vous souhaitiez que
les français en quelque sorte sortent de
la naïveté et du fantasme concernant le
numérique alors naïveté je ne sais pas
s'ils sont naïfs
le fantasme en fait tout de même il ya
quand même suffisamment dallaire t2 et
de danger et ça explique la réticence
des français sur l'utilisation des
applications
je pense que les français s'ils ont
quelques craintes elles sont tout de
même fondé alors
vous avez développé des assurances
concernant la sécurité
mais est-ce que vous pouvez maintenant
développer vous avez dit que le système
que les tessons maîtrise mais est-ce que
vous pouvez développer
justement cette notion de sécurité des
données comment elle est réellement
assurée et puis dernière question en
fait on est dans une phase on a un peu
tous le sentiment que ce stock au vide
est un échec dans son utilisation
aujourd'hui on est sur un un rebond de 2
crise épidémique
on n'entend plus du tout parler du
système il ya plus du tout de
communication alors que peut-être vous
êtes les premiers convaincu de son bien
fondé
pourquoi est-ce qu'il ya plus de
communication gouvernementale sur le
système merci donc je crois qu'on peut
commencer par monsieur sportys et puis
non je prends la malasie attriste donc
je vais tâcher de répondre aux quatre
questions que vous avez posé la première
concerne les métriques sur le système
stop qu'ovide alors en date de ce jour
sept heures on peut considérer qu'il ya
plus de 2 5 millions d'applications qui
ont été téléchargées pour un peu plus
d'un million de désinstallation et pour
un peu plus de 300000 réinstallation
donc on peut considérer qu'il ya environ
1,8 million d'applications qui sont
encore installés
deuxième élément de métriques il nous
est impossible de connaître le nombre
d'utilisateurs effectifs de
l'application stopped vite ça faisait
partie des éléments de conception de
respect total de la vie privée c'est des
implications de ça donc on ne sait pas
combien d'utilisateurs active ou pas
l'application à l'utilisateur peut
l'avoir téléchargé mais ne jamais
l'activer ça on ne sait pas et c'est
vraiment par par conception de
l'application une énorme contrainte pour
respect de la vie privée
après sur les éléments d'utiliser de
metric sur la gestion sanitaire on va
dire donc le système stop qu'ovide donne
lieu à une déclaration de de positivité
de la part d'une personne qui a reçu un
test positif de la part de son
laboratoire et une fois que la personne
décide de partager son historique de
contact avec d'autres smartphones ces
autres smartphones appartenant à des
personnes identifiées comme étant
potentiellement à risque eh bien ces
contacts vont être remontés sur un
serveur central sécurisé donc un premier
élément de metric sait combien de
personnes ont scanné un qr code qui est
présent sur les résultats des analyses
médicales pour accepter de par tf1 de
qu'un calcul d'exposition aux risques
soient effectués à partir de la
positivité donc ce jour il ya 5100 qr
code qui ont été remontés par des
utilisateurs et ensuite l'autre élément
c'est que le serveur central va être
capable de calculer une exposition aux
risques de manière anonyme pour des
utilisateurs de ce top ville est-ce que
moi utilisateurs de ce top cow vite j'ai
été exposé à un moment à une personne
qui a déclaré sa positivité donc sans
les notifications que vous avez évoquées
et à ce jour il y a eu plus de 300 307
exactement déclarations de notification
qui ont décision de notification qui ont
été faites dont 268 ont été effectués le
différentiel sait simplement qu'il ya
des notifications qui aimeraient faire
le système mais qui correspondent
probablement à des personnes qui ont
désinstaller l'application
voilà les éléments de métriques en
réponse à votre première question
la deuxième question correspondait à
horgues ray de madame la maire de paris
sur un non partage d'informations sur
les clusters et donc
la conception de ce top cow vite fait
qu'il n'y a absolument aucune
géolocalisation c'est aussi un élément
de impliqué par la conception
extrêmement strictes sur le respect de
la vie privée donc nous n'avons aucun
élément de géolocalisation qu'il n'ya
rien à partager
nous ne pouvons pas avoir l'information
par exemple selon laquelle 10 % des 5000
qr code qui ont été remontés
correspondre à la région ile de france
nous ne l'avons pas l'information selon
lequel cinq pour cent des notifications
lieu en gironde nous ne l'avons pas non
plus voilà donc c'est par conception
c'est absolument pas possible
la troisième question portait sur
l'expression que j'ai utilisée de
naïveté et de fantasmes numérique qui
était surtout un regret de ma part sur
le fait que sur un sujet aussi compliqué
que cela pour lequel je comprends les
réactions que peut avoir que peuvent
avoir nos concitoyens dans les deux sens
eh bien il faut du temps pour pouvoir
installer des éléments d'explication des
risques des avantages de l'arbitrage
entre les avantages et les risques des
solutions techniques qui sont mis en
place pour pouvoir répondre à des
craintes qui sont légitimes et mon
regretté que le dialogue science
technology société sur des sujets aussi
compliqué que cela eh bien il faut du
temps pour les installer et plus
globalement qui mettrait économie
numérique qui comprend ce qui se passe
sur le web qui comprend qu est ce qui
est fait de ces données personnelles mon
regret sur sa sur le fait qu'il faut
plus de temps pour installer sereinement
ce débat sachant que je comprends tout à
fait les les craintes qui peuvent être
exprimés ou avait demandé également dans
cette question quels étaient les
éléments de réassurance on va dire que
nous étions capables de fournir
donc je suis le fait par exemple qu'il
n'y ait aucune géolocalisation est un
élément de leur assurance le fait que à
ma connaissance cette application a été
l'une des voir la plus scrutée par son
autorité administrative indépendante
qui en charge du respect de la
protection de la vie privée et des
données numériques à savoir la cnil avec
plusieurs avis montrent qu' il ya
quelque chose qui est cohérent avec le
cadre démocratique dans lequel une somme
soit si ça c'est pour l'aspect la vie
privée sur la cybersécurité l'agencé
nationale de sécurité des systèmes
d'information a été impliqué dès le
début dans le projet et a mis en place
avec nous un programme de 60 points à
respecter qui ont été respectées en
termes de sécurité tout au lond avons
même organisé un un ouverture du système
à une communauté de hackers blancs un
hacker blanc c'est un pirate
informatique qui acceptent de travailler
du bon côté pour déceler des failles on
va dire sur un système
ça a été fait en toute transparence avec
la société ix à souillac est organisée
avec l'anzhi et ça n'a donné lieu à
aucune identification de failles
importantes on va dire voilà donc ça
c'est les éléments de ces les éléments
de réassurance et ce qui n'empêche pas
qui évidemment c'est un sujet permanent
que de garantir que nous continuons à
respecter la vie privée
nous continuons à améliorer le système
en termes de cybersécurité est la
dernière question correspondent est sûre
pour reprendre votre terme l'échec
d'adoption ou l'échec d'utilisation
donc je n'ai pas à commenter c'est un
élément de votre question la politique
de communication globale qui est faite
par le gouvernement dans le cadre de la
stratégie du général de gestion de la
crise sanitaire gévia menthe à l'eau
commenté dans le cadre de mes fonctions
ce que je peux juste partager c'est
qu'évidemment qu'une action d'une unité
de ce type est d'autant plus efficace
qu'il est largement utilisé et il faut
juste avoir un chiffre en tête en toute
théorie parce que la vie un peu plus
compliqué bien sûr mais en toute théorie
le nombre de notifications qui est est
fondamentalement le nombre de contacts
détectés par l'application est bien
croit comme le carré du nombre des
utilisateurs ce qui veut dire que
actuellement nous avons pour faire très
simple
que 2 millions d'applications si nous
multiplions par cinq le nombre
d'utilisateurs de cette application pour
autant qu'il active et que là pour
mémoire l'allemagne 20 millions
d'applications qui ont été téléchargées
si nous mais à deux fois moins de cuir
deux fois moins de déclarations de
positivité
par ailleurs des connaissances public
nous avons dessiné multipliant par cinq
le nombre d'utilisateurs est bien en
multipliant toute théorie ça sera
évidemment plus compliqué par 25 le
nombre de contacts traité pour calculer
une exposition risques et partant
probablement de notification donc le
sujet de l'adoption de la capacité à
faire adopter pour autant que ça rentre
dans une stratégie globale de santé et
bien et est évidemment clé à ce titre
merci bernard cheviet merci monsieur le
président de questions quelques
remarques quand même sur la partie cnam
excusez moi avec question madame là le
rapporteur sur la transmission des
informations aux collectivités
territoriales sur les clusters
peut-être que terol blanc m'avait juste
vous rappeler le process et le fait
qu'effectivement aujourd'hui les textes
nous interdisent de passer ce type
d'information mais peut-être rappeler a
pu dire en introduction sur
l'organisation du trail singh on a dit
qu'en fait les médecins et aussi les
établissements de santé intervenez dans
le tracking en premier niveau
l'assurance maladie prend le relais et
en troisième niveau en fait les ars
interviennent et l'ensemble des données
qui sont collectés dans outils aux
contacts ovi qu'on a présenté tout à
l'heure et la date de dimanche soir on
avait quand même finalement pu
enregistrer de 124 mille personnes
positives et 8 126 mille personnes
contacts donc l'ensemble de ces données
est transmis à la rs de façon à ce que
la grèce puisse remplir sa mission de
détection des clusters et de veille
sanitaire et épidémiologique donc en
fait les informations qui sont rentrés
permettent en fait d'identifier le lieu
où la personne positive et ces constats
et ses contacts vive et c'est de cette
façon par agrégation que les autorités
sanitaires sont en capacité de déceler
des lieux où la multiplication des cas
leur permettent de penser qu'elle a une
chaîne de contamination qui s'apparente
à un cluster et de prendre finalement
les mesures d'ordre public approprié
pour limiter ces chaînes de
contamination et 7 luster met donc
aujourd'hui ces informations nous ne
sommes autorisés à nous les communiquer
qu'à la rs laquelle après a en charge la
gestion de du cluster en lien évidemment
avec les collectivités territoriales ou
les établissements sanitaires concernées
merci vous pensez que si c'était
communiqué ce serait important
ça permettrait de si ces informations
étaient communiquées aux collectivités
locales ça permettrait peut-être de
prendre des mesures plus rapidement ou
pas non en tout cas ces informations
sont extrêmement sensibles comme on
disait
l'outil l'outil qu'on a trop vite fait
l'objet d'un encadrement cnil
extrêmement précis et voilà les mesures
barrières respect de en tout cas nous
voilà dans quand on fait le tracking
il nous est demandé aux médecins comme à
nous de repérer les personnes ayant
besoin d'un accompagnement social
donc on le pose un certain nombre de
questions donc du coup on pose à la
personne un certain nombre de questions
sur des critères de vulnérabilité type
est ce qu'elle est enceinte
le poids des choses comme ça et puis des
questions sur le son environnement un
peu sociale est ce qu'elle est dans un
logement insalubre
ce qu'elle vit ce qu on est beaucoup
dans ce logement est ce que du coup les
conditions d'isolement vont être
difficiles à respecter ça ça nous permet
de savoir s'il ya un besoin
d'accompagnement social et les textes
ont encadré le fait que même cette
information nous ne pouvons pas la
communiquer aux cellules territoriales
d'appui à l'isolement-- qui ont été
mises en place nous deux nous nous
identifions qu'il ya un besoin nous en
parlons à la personne et non recueillons
son consentement sur le fait qu' il ya
un besoin et on lui donne l'information
le numéro de téléphone qu'elle puisse
appeler la cellule territoriale d'appui
à l'isolément c'est pas nous qui donnons
l'information à la cellule territoriale
d'appui l isolement parce que le holà le
vérifier que la personne ne fasse bien
vous avez moyen vous rappelez derrière
extérieur c'est pas le rôle de
l'assurance maladie ont fait le rôle de
clients de vérifier de façon générale
tout on va dire les opérations qui vont
relever du suivi du confinement c'est à
dire une fois que la personne a été
identifiée et que lui ont été transmises
les mesures à mettre en place en fait en
termes de dépistage isolement et c'est
le la répartition des rôles fait que sar
bascule du côté de la rs qui a en place
un dispositif de suivi de l'isolant avec
des rappels et des contacts réguliers de
la personne je ne ne suis pas vos
conseils restent isolés oui mais ça ça a
été un choix enfin effectivement ça a
été un choix
il ya une censure du conseil non mais
d'accord mais vous couriez relancer ou
quelqu'un pourrait relancer la personne
pour effectivement l'ol est relancé
palais merci ça fait combien pas
communiquer l'information la sibérie
mais le personne n'est pas merci
monsieur prix dans deux questions la
première va faire suite à cette
discussion actuellement la stratégie
tester tracé isolés on va lire et en
relatif échec
en tout cas elle fait face à de graves
difficultés beaucoup se concentre sur la
1ère étape tester
maintenant il est bien établi que les
délais d'accès aux tests et de autour
des résultats dépasse souvent la période
de contagiosité et met en échec donc
toute la suite de la stratégie dont un
certain nombre de mesures ont été prises
très récemment pour essayer d'y parer je
ne reviens pas sur cette première marche
la seconde marche c'est le traçage et là
il semblerait aussi que les difficultés
soit soit importante et une information
a été publiée il ya quelques jours vous
la confirmer ou pas établissant que des
personnes qui ont été trouvées comme
positive dans la deuxième semaine de
septembre
quatre sur cinq n'avaient pas été
identifiées comme qu'à contacter ce qui
veut dire que les chaînes de
transmission échappent largement à la
stratégie du tra singh ce qui serait le
témoin d'une grande difficulté à freiner
donc la circulation du virus pour ce qui
est de ce pilier de la stratégie je
parle pas des masques et des et des
gestes de distanciation physique
donc est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire à
ce jour à quelle proportion de personnes
dépistées positives
vous estimez celles pour lesquelles un
contact et intra singh est réellement
effectués et deuxièmement est ce que oui
ou non vous êtes actuellement en
capacité de répondre à la hausse de la
circulation du virus
en procédant à ce contact racing pour
l'ensemble des personnes positives et
j'ai bien je ne demande pas à d'autres
j'ai bien noté que le premier ministre a
annoncé de nouveaux moyens en personnel
et que sera 2011 recrutement voilà etc
mais je voudrais savoir exactement
quelle est la situation aujourd'hui et
nous ne parlerons pas puisque ce n'est
pas votre sujet direct même s'il
échanges précédents l'évoquer
la troisième étape de cette stratégie
qui est l'isolément
on a tous noté que dans le débat public
on n'entend plus du tout parler de lieux
ou de propositions qui seraient faites à
des personnes positives pour être isolé
quand leurs conditions de logement ne le
permet pas actuellement
donc peut-être que dans deux mois on se
réveillera aussi à ce sujet
progressivement et et on continuera au
fil de l'eau j'ai une deuxième question
quand on a un téléphone portable un
smartphone et qui on a le système ios et
qu'on met à jour son téléphone portable
qu on migre vers ios 13.7 en soi un
petit message qui dit ios 13.7 vous
permet d'activer le système de
notifications d'exposition pour le coc
vide 19 sans avoir à télécharger
d'application la disponibilité du
système dépend de la prise en charge de
votre autorité de santé publique
est ce que les autorités sanitaires
n'ont pas le sentiment de se faire trop
les par apple
merci
en complément puisque j'avais une
question qui va tout à fait dans le même
sens que 7 des contacts c'est combien de
jours après le test contacter voulait
les personnes contacts et d'une personne
donc testé positivement les délais merci
en complément le bernard leblanc vous
avez la parole
merci monsieur le président donc sur la
première question monsieur le rapporteur
a indiqué qu en effet quatre personnes
sur cinq qui sont positives n'était pas
qu'à contacter avant en effet c'est un
chiffre qu'on formule autrement mais qui
revient à la même chose c'est-à-dire
qu'en effet nous avons 20 % des cas
contacts qui deviennent personnes
infectées qu'ovide ce qui veut dire que
il y à des chaînes de transmission qu'on
ne sait pas retracé notamment parce que
lorsqu'on est dans un lieu public et que
le lieu public et la contamination du
lieu de contamination la personne
infectée ne sait pas nécessairement
identifier quels sont les contacts qui
lui ont effectivement été rattachés donc
on a en effet on ne sommes pas en
capacité de tracer 100 % des personnes
contactent nominativement de façon à
pouvoir les rappeler derrière ensuite le
deuxième effet c'est que la levée de la
prescription a généré finalement une
accélération du recours aux tests avec
pour effet que certaines personnes en
fait
arrive un statut de personnes infectées
p 0 avant même de passer par le stade
entre guillemets qu'à contacter ce qui
fait que ces deux effets cumulés nous
avons le même constat que le vôtre à
savoir que statistiquement on a en effet
20% seulement des des personnes pzero
qui étaient d'anciens dans sept
personnes enregistrées comme qu'un
contact en ce qui concerne les effectifs
de l'assurance-maladie
lorsque le
cette mission vous a été confié en fait
au mois de mai nous avons formé dans une
première vague 3000 personnes puis 6000
personnes
nous avons entre guillemets un peu revu
notre organisation au mois de juin
puisque finalement l'épidémie était à
cette époque dans une personne dans une
période basse et puis nous avons
réactivé notre organisation
départementale dès la mi juillet et
depuis elle ne cesse de monter en fête
en puissance
aujourd'hui on a à peu près dix mille
personnes qui collaborent au dispositif
de tra singh au sein des caisses
primaires d'assurance maladie et des
services médicaux de l'assurance maladie
ces personnes en fait ont bénéficié du
renfort de personnel en cdd en
particulier je rappelle que ces
plateformes travail en fait 7 jours sur
7 que le travail du dimanche pour lequel
nous avons reçu donc une autorisation
précise réglementaire pour nous le
permettre repose néanmoins sur la base
du volontariat et que sur la durée nous
avons besoin aussi de pouvoir assurer la
soutenabilité du dispositif et c'est
pour ça que nous faisons également appel
à des personnels cdd pour compléter nos
effectifs
ceci étant donc ces personnes mobilisées
nous permettent aujourd'hui de gérer à
peu près 40 mille appels par jour c'est
ce que nous avons fait toute la semaine
dernière et nous nous préparons pour
pouvoir continuer à augmenter cette
cadence puisque je crois que chacun a
bien compris qu'on était pas arrivé au
pic en fait de de l'épidémie sur la
question vous avez posé sur ios c
j'ai pas deux sur le délai par manque
sûrement sur le délai aujourd'hui on a
un délai moyen entre le moment où on a
identifié une personne infectée qu'ovide
et le moment où on rappelle son cas
contacts qui est de 1,7 jours pour avoir
réussi à appeler le cas contacts il faut
savoir qu on appelle les cas contacts
entre trois et quatre fois pour réussir
à les joindre et donc moi je vous parle
bien d'un appel aboutit et pas d'un
premier contact avec le cas contact sur
la question des effectifs
je lui présente le rapporteur bon sans
surprise en réponse à votre question
de mon point de vue la réponse est oui à
votre question je vais développer un
tout petit peu donc effectivement à
l'arrivée le sujet c'est le système
d'exploitation c'est-à-dire cette couche
logicielle qui permet de rendre
intelligent un smartphone et là vous
évoquer ce thème des logiciels système
d'exploitation ios développé par apple
effectivement s'il ya eu un choix de
développer une application stop&go vide
qui ne repose pas sur cette
fonctionnalité qui est descendue
maintenant dans le système
d'exploitation
et bien c'est pour une question de
maîtrise par l'autorité de santé il y à
de la science qui a été fait ça veut
dire qu'il a donné lieu à des
publications
il ya un développement qui a été fait en
open source c'est à dire que les codes
logiciels sont tous disponibles et ce
n'est pas nécessairement le cas de ce
qui est dans un système d'exploitation
il ya un niveau de sécurité un niveau de
respect de la vie privée ça a été posée
de tout à l'heure par madame la
sénatrice vermeille et qui est qui est
sous contrôle de notre société
démocratique via ces autorités
administratives indépendantes qui donne
un cadre qui vérifie que ce cadre est
mis en oeuvre il ya des métriques j'ai
répondu alors une question sur les
métriques
nous pouvons vous donner à peu près en
temps réel et des choses qu'on ne peut
pas vous donner par conception j'ai
répondu mais on est capable de vous
donner le nombre de déclarations de
positivité qui ont transité le nombre de
notifications un système fondé sur
le la brique logicielle que on va dire
développé par apple et google ne permet
pas à ma connaissance haute autorité de
santé de connaître ces éléments aussi
simple ces éléments si simple de metric
et il ya une boucle de rétroaction qui
est et d'améliorations qui est sous
maîtrise de l'autorité de santé il reste
beaucoup à faire parce qu'évidemment
l'impact sanitaire serait de savoir tout
en respectant les contraintes de vie
privée combien de personnes qui viennent
avec une notification stop que vides qui
viennent après un parcours médical se
faire tester combien correspondent
effectivement par exemple à une
positivité derrière c'est une boucle de
rétroaction qui serait extrêmement
intéressante avec des chiffres plus gros
pour améliorer le système
donc tous ces éléments font que il ya un
système de maîtrise qui a été adoptée
par la france et je veux juste finir
au-delà de la gestion de la crise
sanitaire
pour moi ça démontre bien que ce qui
n'est pas vraiment la crise sanitaire
que les systèmes d'exploitation sont des
infrastructures qui sont des
infrastructures immatériel donc on a
moins de peine moins de plus de
difficultés à les appréhender que les
routes que les systèmes bancaires
mais ce sont les infrastructures de
notre économie et de notre société et à
titre personnel je pense que le débat de
la régulation et devrait être posée et
notamment la lumière de cette crise
sanitaire
ça confirme et bon jeu là la réponse est
tout à fait satisfaisante merci mais on
va dire la vraie réponse appartient aux
autorités politiques
voilà merci kettering merci monsieur le
président et moi j'avais une question
concernant contacts qu vite parce que on
a reçu un rapport de la cnil
hier qui fait état dans son rapport
global sur le fichier contact qu'ovide
d'anomalies importantes dont elle donne
deux exemples c'est des envois par des
cpm à la rs de données de santé via des
messageries non sécurisés et l'envoi par
un établissement de santé de données de
santé relative aux qu'ovide inscrits sur
un fichier distincts à l'instruction
même de la cnam qu'est ce qui a été fait
pour corriger ces anomalies
ça c'était ma première question la
deuxième question c'est sûr essayer d
exemple dans les autres pays d'europe
qui sont confrontés à la même
problématique des stés tracé isolé de
d'applications style stop qu'ovide
est-ce que vous en avez connaissance et
puis à un débat qui sort un peu que
celui en effet des hébergeurs à une
pétition d'ailleurs sur le site du sénat
sur sur pourquoi le health date avait
confié à microsoft et non pas un
hébergeur européen on avait avec rené
paul savary d'ailleurs reçu fait une
audition sur cette thématique sur le
système actuel choisi on est on est bien
sûr un hébergeur européen
voilà mes trois questions merci l'homme
blanc
madame la rapporteure donc sur les deux
questions concernant l'utilisation de
messagerie simple et non crypté pour
communiquer à la rs comme nous disions
tout à l'heure lorsque des cours en fait
du traçage nous repérons une personne
infectée qui auraient eu des contacts
particulièrement à risque par exemple au
sein d'une collectivité type un ehpad
une crèche ou même un nombre de contacts
très important parce que ayant participé
à un rassemblement
ceci fait l'objet d'un signalement d'un
sein d'un enregistrement dans la base et
cet enregistrement dans la base est
doublée d'un signalement à la rs pour
attirer son attention et pour que celles
ci puissent d'emblée analyser la
situation et évaluer le risque de
clusters ce signalement se fait par
message est simple mais il ne comporte
aucune données nominatives
et aucune donnée de santé puisque nous
alertons la rs par le biais du numéro de
fiches c'est à dire comme la rsa
complètement accès à contacter qu'ovide
mais que simplement l'outil ne ne
ne comprend pas de système intégré d'
alerte si vous voulez pour faciliter la
recherche par la rs nous attirons son
attention par le biais de mails où nous
lui disons merci de bien vouloir
analyser la fiche numéro exane de 34
afin de d'évaluation des risques de
clusters donc en effet nous nous faisons
ces échanges par messagerie mais ils ne
comprennent pas de données nominatives
et de données médicales concernant les
fichiers qui sont transmis par les
établissements on l'a dit tout à l'heure
les professionnels de santé libéraux
sont des sources de détection de
personnes infectées et de prise en
charge mais des établissements de santé
aussi en particulier pour les personnes
hospitalisées ou pour les résidents
lorsque ces établissements gère des des
ehpad ou des établissements médico
sociaux en général et donc dans ce cadre
là ils doivent être en capacité de
pouvoir enregistrer des personnes
infectées qu'ovide également de tracer
leur cas contactez le désormais les
établissements peuvent avoir recours à
un accès direct à cette application
contact qu'ovide qui n'étaient pas
opérationnels au démarrage du processus
donc au démarrage du processus nous
avons mis en place une alternative
permettant de pouvoir récolter ces
informations aient mené les opérations
de racing et nous avons demandé aux
établissements de remplir un fichier
excel et de nous l'a dressé mais
uniquement et c'est ce qui est fait par
messagerie sécurisée de santé ars mss
entre l'établissement d'une part et le
service médical de l'assurance maladie
de l'autre et nous récupérons ainsi ces
données et nous nous substituons à
l'établissement pour la saisie d'un
contact au vide puisque l'établissement
dans un premier temps n'avait pas accès
à contacter provident
et aujourd'hui encore certains
établissements notamment les plus petits
ne se sont pas forcément équipés de
façon à pouvoir utiliser l'application
directe et continue à nous faire des
signalements par ce biais mais j'insiste
c'est toujours par le biais de la
messagerie sécurisée en santé
jeux sportifs jeux vice-présidence
répondre aux 2 questions de madame la
rapporteure donc la première cause
question concerne sur les autres
applications dans d'autres pays
européens donc on va dire la plupart des
pays européens se sont effectivement
doté d'applications on travaille avec
des équipes européennes dès le début
depuis le début du projet j'ai rappelé
que la génèse de l'application stop
qu'ovide c'est un projet franco allemand
et il ya eu et donc ce qui est dans ce
top coville est en fait le résultat d'un
projet franco-allemand et puis une
décision politique à un moment qui à
emprunter d'autres voies
on a un travail avec les autres équipes
européennes depuis le début et il ya des
choix qui ont été faits par les autres
pays de reposer sur la boîte à outils
proposés par apple et google
et là je vous renvoie à la question
précédente on va te dire sur ce sujet il
n'y a pas de compatibilité simple entre
les deux systèmes pour une raison
extrêmement facile à appréhender
c'est que la nature des informations qui
circulent n'a rien à voir dans le cadre
du système développé par apple et google
mon statut de positivité se retrouve
sous une forme indirecte dans votre
smartphone et dans le smartphone de tous
les utilisateurs ce qui nous a semblé
nous dès le début un sujet de respect de
la vie privée et de cybersécurité majeur
ce qu'ont montré plusieurs articles
scientifiques depuis plusieurs mois dans
le cadre du système français
cette information reste dans mon
smartphone et il y à un partage des
contacts exposé à risques de manière on
va dire pseudo nos miser avec un serveur
central chez nos amis allemands
alors les l'allemagne a choisi comme
d'autres pays européens le système afin
de s'appuyer sur le système développé
par apple et google
ils ont pas fait un autre système à
l'allemande comme nous nous avons fait
un système à la france
initialement nous avons travaillé
ensemble ce qui a conduit il ya une
décision politique est un moment qui
m'appartient évidemment pas de commenter
de passer à un autre système
et concernant votre deuxième question
sur le lte à table donc je n'ai pas de
lille
limiter d'autant plus dans ce cadre à
répondre il me semble que la question
que vous posez aussi par exemple celle
de la réversibilité des des solutions
d'hébergement choisi qu un sujet sur
lequel une aria souvent pris position il
n'ya qui par ailleurs membre fondateur
du wef data up jeep club
et en ce qui concerne ce top cow vide
l'hébergeur qui choisit qui a été
choisie est un hébergeur qui est out ce
qu'elle donc dassault systèmes qui est
le seul la seule solution d'hébergement
ce cloud ne m'excuserai de l'anglicisme
qui a été certifié au plus haut niveau
de sécurité par l'ansi c'est la
certification dit secure cloud
voilà et c'est le choix qui a été fait
pour avoir la maîtrise planer entière ou
vite dassault systèmes outscale français
mais bien sûr entièrement français merci
vous avez identifié les blocages que
l'on constate qu'ils font que stop kovy
de n'est pas plus utilisé
on a plusieurs enquêtes qui ont été
réalisés qui sont encore en cours
l'absence de tout développeur
d'applications c'est que pour faire
rentrer une application par adopter une
application il faut faire beaucoup
beaucoup de communication dans la durée
on a une très grande élasticité vous
m'excuserez du terme de toute promotion
qu'on constate une très grande
élasticité de toute promotion positive
de personnes éminentes de ministres sur
l'adoption enfin sur le taux de
téléchargement
quand monsieur le premier ministre fait
une intervention une conférence de
presse
il ya deux trois semaines je crois avec
le monsieur le ministre de la santé et
des solidarités où il reprend me stoppe
cowitz est vrai que ce jour là nous
constatons une multiplication par 4 ou 5
du taux de téléchargement
mais le lendemain seul art décline parce
que la question une application mobile
enfin le monde numérique va vous le
savez comme utilisateur par ailleurs
martèle je m'excuse du terme en
permanence pour pour adopter en plus un
objet qui est nouveau est un objet qui
enfin dans la discuter pose plein de
questions tout à fait légitimes et j'en
reviens mac est mon point de tout à
l'heure qui est que installer un débat
serein en parallèle le prend du temps
voilà donc ça c'est un élément
oui mais il ya eu à gérer beaucoup de
choses et j'ai répondu tout à l'heure et
par ailleurs il y as je veux dire il ya
évidemment parfois on continue à avoir
des bugs techniques qui remonte qui
peuvent dans certains cas aussi
peut-être
on va faire que ponctuellement quelqu'un
qui a une certaine version d'un certain
terminale parce que un parc de
téléphones est extrêmement diversifié
donc le fait que nous en effet les choix
d'essayer de soutenir sur tout le parc
pour la plupart enfin pour tout ce que
l'on pouvait deux versions de système
d'exploitation un vrai les implications
de développement mais on a des systèmes
qui reste encore à améliorer et tous les
jours on continue à essayer des amis ça
peut aussi jouer pour certaines
personnes mais notre année c'est d'abord
le sujet de l'adoption
merci sylvie vermeillet juste une petite
précision vous avez indiqué tout à
l'heure 20 millions d'applications
téléchargées en allemagne donc c'est une
différence de communication qu'est ce
qui explique ce taux plus élevés alors
je m'attarde très très loin de mes bases
de légitimité mais probablement des
éléments de politique de communication
qui n'ont pas été les mêmes d'un pays à
un autre et puis plus largement et c'est
là où je m'engage très loin de mes bases
légitimité de ma base de légitimité
il ya aussi la relation du citoyen dans
un pays à son état qui doit jouer un
très grand rôle
j'imagine et je pense que ça doit jouer
aussi culturellement
oui par rapport à cette comparaison avec
l'allemagne peut être aussi on peut
penser que le fait d'avoir une politique
de tests très rapide et donc avec
l'efficacité que ça a montré sur les
résultats en terme de mortalité
notamment à donner confiance aux
citoyens allemands ce qui n'est pas le
cas chez nous un moment on s'est
retrouvés il fallait gérer vite des
tests alors qu'avant on ne faisait pas
il fallait mettre l'application tous a
généré à mon sens beaucoup de d'angoissé
beaucoup d'interrogations et on voit
bien que là puisque c'est aussi un des
objets de notre commission denquête le
parallèle affaire ne sera pas simplement
que sur certains points de tester autre
mais vraiment sur un système de global
de confiance entre la parole publique et
le citoyen le site mais juste pour bien
clair en allemagne si le système apple
google donc ils ne cherchent ils ne
télécharge pas l'application ne charge
pas l'application
ils ont directement alors en fait il ya
eu une chronologie de l'action d'apple
et google sur le sujet c'est avec dans
un premier temps ils ont proposé une
boîte à outils ce qu'on appelle désolé
du jargon informatique une api pour les
développeurs d'applications et tous les
pays européens
à ma connaissance du fait de la
chronologie ont utilisé cette boîte à
ceux qui ont opté pour la solution apple
google ont utilisé cette boîte à outils
en développement au dessus une
application mais qui de fait avec tout
le respect que je dois aux autres
équipes techniques comportait beaucoup
moins d'éléments puisqu'elle utiliser
cette boîte à outils et dans un deuxième
temps apple et google ont fait descendre
ses fonctionnalités dans le terminal
c'était la question de monsieur le
sénateur tout à l'heure dans ce qu'on
appelle le système d'exploitation c'est
à dire que c'est une fonctionnalité
native sur votre téléphone qui permet de
fait de tracer indépendamment de
l'existence d'une application de santé
ce qui pose des questions alors ce ne
sont pas les allemands mais c'est ce
qu'évoquait monsieur est un pays qui se
lanceraient maintenant et donc les
allemands ils sont à ma connaissance
sont dans la première mouture où il
utilise une boîte à outils disponibles
mais
à charge et donc ils ont une application
à télécharger qui repose sur le système
apple et google
merci à ma connaissance voilà c'est pour
la clarté du débat parce que c'est
important ça pouvait être le fait de
charger ou pas l'application est bien
télécharge merci alors nous allons
passer aux questions des commissaires je
vais regroupés il y en a trois
angèle préville merci monsieur le
président donc c'est d'abord une
première question pour moi suce portis
s'agissant vous avez parlé des garanties
de respect de la vie privée sur la cbr
sécurité heureux mois d'après ce que je
sais on n'est jamais on n'a jamais la
garantie à 100% que ces choses là
puissent effectivement respecter
entièrement et la vie privée et la cyber
sécurité on a des exemples notamment sur
des hackers qui ont pu par exemple je
crois que c'est en norvège a acquis
toutes les deux la moitié des données de
santé des norvégiens je crois donc il ya
une appétence très forte
c'est des choses qui circulent comme ça
dans le monde actuel sur la captation de
données pour faire tourner les
intelligences artificielles et pour
faire d'autres actions donc je vais pas
parler là donc effectivement peut-être
que les questionnements il est là sur
est-ce qu'on est une garantie à 100% de
ce respect d'une part et d'autre part
il me semble que le système parce que
vous avez parlé de ce qui existe en
allemagne et des skis et de ce qui est
utilisé par apple google repose pas tout
à fait sur le même système
moi je suis pas technicienne mais j'ai
cru comprendre que c'étaient deux
systèmes différents fait de stockage est
donné et c'est vrai qu'on peut se poser
la question
quelque part les données de
géolocalisation elles sont quelque part
quand même même si elles n'apparaissent
pas est-ce que par le fait d'un hacker
on peut pas quand même remonter mon
c'est une question un peu naïve
peut-être mais voilà c'est une question
que je me pose
alors après sur donc des questions pour
pour pour mesdames de la caisse
d'assurance maladie
c'est sûr quand vous êtes face à une
personne donc avec contact qu'ovide qui
est contacts et donc vous l'après venez
et vous lui dit d'aller se faire tester
est-ce qu'elle a pour aller se faire
tester une priorité comment ça se passe
exactement à ce que vous lui dites vous
pouvez aller vous faire tester à tel
endroit et vous allez être prêt
aujourd'hui prise aujourd'hui ou pas
parce que si la personne est laissée
face à elle-même comment comment elle
procède
est-ce que c'est fait rapidement et puis
après une autre question quand vous
quand la personne donc est positive et
qu'elle doit s'isoler et vous avez
évoqué les problèmes sociaux
effectivement qu'il peut y avoir mais il
peut y avoir aussi c'est notamment le
cas dans les métropoles où les
appartements où le son petit et donc
s'il n'y a pas forcément un problème
social
mais il ya un problème et ça a été
évoqué par mon collègue tout à l'heure
de d'isoler et de l'impossibilité de
s'isoler
donc c'est vrai qu'on n'entend pas trop
parler actuellement de ses possibilités
là est-ce que vous pouvez nous en dire
davantage vous remercie merci laurence
cohen
oui merci monsieur le président beaucoup
de questions ont déjà été posées mais
c'est vrai qu'on a on constaté vous
l'avez d'ailleurs redit l'échec de ceux
de ce système
et hier j'entendais le secrétaire d'état
chargé du numérique cedrico dire que en
fait c'était une histoire de pédagogie
et que les françaises et les français
n'auraient pas bien compris alors je
trouve que l'explication est un peu
courte parce que à chaque fois que le
gouvernement est défaillant c'est
toujours une histoire de pédagogie parce
qu'ils ont mal expliquer les choses à
croire que nos concitoyennes et nos
concitoyens ont un pouvoir de
compréhension limitée
moi je partage pas je partage pas cette
analyse
mais je pense que ça fait partie d'un
tout c'est à dire que on peut pas
détaché ce système du fait que les tests
la mise en place des tests le le fait de
lait de les réaliser et les résultats
prennent un temps assez assez long trop
long
et en plus avec des inégalités
territoriales extrêmement forte
donc c'est une source de pertes aussi de
confiance par rapport à aux françaises
et aux français qui ne trouve pas un
système finalement qui peut les
accompagner les aider en termes de tests
comme hier en terme de deux masques donc
il me semble que ça ça explique en
partie ya pas que ça mais ça explique en
partie cette cette défiance qu'il ya en
plus et je partage ce que vient de dire
ma ma collègue c'est à dire que quand
même au niveau de la protection des
données de la remise en cause éventuelle
des libertés etc
il ya aussi tous acquis qui plane la
deuxième chose parce que hier j'étais
sur le plateau de public sénat et j'ai
été interrogé là-dessus notamment est la
question qui m'avait été posée c'est de
dire est ce que vous ne croyez pas que
le fait que le système qui a été mis en
place en france on insiste m je veux
dire comme ça pour aller vite
adil france alors que dans les autres
pays européens ils ont pris tout va clé
en main et c est ce que ceci ne pas
expliquer l'échec
personnellement je ne le pense pas parce
que je pense que là on est en plein dans
les gaffes à etc
mais quel est votre votre appréciation
est ce que finalement vous pensez que il
y à des défaillances peut-être dans la
façon dont le système pu être présentés
et les liens que vous avez pu établir
avec les personnes quand elles sont
déclarées contacts que vous les avez au
téléphone est très différente
je vous remercie merci victoire jasmin
et même si monsieur le président alors
j'ai trois questions s'agissant des
procédures simplifiées qui ont été mises
en oeuvre
parce que eux on passe d'un système mots
pour faire un certain nombre d'analystes
d'examens de laboratoire il fallait
préalablement qu'il y ait une
prescription médicale
maintenant on a raccourci donc on fait
aussi dieu qui permet d'aller dans un
laboratoire avec une carte vitale et une
adresse mail pour avoir un résultat et
en même temps on ne se rend compte que
dans les dispositions qui ont été mises
en oeuvre et il ya également les
laboratoires de biologie vétérinaire en
tout cas qui ont été sollicités alors je
voudrais savoir quelles sont les actions
qui sont les vôtres
parce que on passe d'un système où il y
à des laboratoires de biologie médicale
que ce soit dans les établissements
publics de santé ou dans les états dans
les laboratoires extra hospitaliers qui
avait les logiciels sécurisés qui
avaient des dispositifs et une
certification en conte et la plupart
accrédités au pas mais qui avait en tout
cas des procédures pré analytique
analytique avec des rendus de résultats
là on passe de système où il faut faire
vite au tout est décalé tout est
réorganisée et l'implication des
laboratoires vétérinaires poser problème
nous avons auditionné il ya quelques
quelques jours des responsables de
laboratoires ont notamment qui nous ont
dit que tous les résultats n'étaient pas
sécurisés dans la mesure où les
laboratoires de biologie vétérinaire
n'avait pas les logiciels compatibles
avec les leurs donc c'était des
transferts de données par les tableurs
excel
alors comment vous situez vous dans
cette démarche est ce qu'il ya une
nomenclature particulière pour ce type
d'examen et des examens successifs et
répétitif en fonction des contacts en
fonction scan id différents niveaux il
ya différents niveaux de prise en charge
de ces tests entre des personnes qui ont
des signes cliniques qui sont qui
arrivent dans les laboratoires avec une
ordonnance des personnes qui doivent
voyager qu'ils ont une contrainte de 72
heures qu'il n'y ait presque jamais
respecté en ce moment avec toutes les
conséquences que cela peut avoir parce
que des personnes sont obligées
quelquefois de refaire une analyse parce
qu'ils n'ont pas eu le résultat dans les
délais et parce que le délai de contrat
de 72 heures étant dépassé le et le
commando invisible
la compagnie aérienne doit demander doit
exiger même que les analyses soient
refaites donc alors cette redondance
danalyse parce qu'il ya le premier qui
est fait on n'a pas eu de livres 72
heures il faut refaire pour rester dans
cette contrainte donc je voudrais savoir
comment vous vous intervenez et là
d'autres choses et vous avez parlé de
également de sécuriser et de
compatibilité de sécurité de données et
vous pensez que tout est sécurisé et
quand on regarde bien avec le succès
manquer de ce top cow vide
donc il ya eu peut-être des prévisions
mais est-ce que c'était suffisamment
clair pour que la jonction entre les
différents systèmes et les personnes
contactées ont fait tous les dispositifs
et les coordinations qui devait se faire
est ce qu'à un moment donné il n'y a pas
eu un échec flagrant parce que quand on
regarde le bilan c'est un bilan qui est
quasiment nulle par rapport à aux
objectifs qui étaient préalablement
denis merci merci
alors nous coupe un pardon je signe
guinness
oui merci président lors de l'audition
au niveau de la corée et de taïwan
on a vu qu'ils ont mis deux tracés en
effet qu'en dira en route et très
rapidement en fin de compte
alors certes on n'a pas les même
mentalité ça c'est sûr on le voit bien
mais en tous les cas on voit aussi le
nombre de morts chez nous par rapport à
chez eux et ici on a été plutôt assez
étonné du résultat
alors moi je suis un peu étonné c'est
que l'application peut le mettre sur nos
téléphones etc et vous avez dit ce
qu'ils ont mis se sont retirés
donc j'aimerais savoir pourquoi où j'ai
mal compris je ne sais pas 1 c'est bien
ça c'est bien compris merci très bonne
question également alors nous allons
commencer par la cnam et puis ensuite je
repasserai la parole à bruno sportisse
alesi dans l'ordre que vous souhaitez
bienvenus merci peut-être pour revenir
sur la façon dont on conduit les
entretiens avec les personnes contactées
répondre à la question de madame donc en
effet l'une des informations principales
que nous délivrons aux personnes lorsque
nous les avons en ligne
il ya bien sûr le fait de récupérer
leurs tests d'aller de se mettre en
isolement et de leur indiquer les bonnes
dur et d'isolement en fonction du moment
où l on les contacte à risque et puis
ensuite d'aller faire pratiquer un test
avec là aussi la bonne date de test
parce que le fait que le test soit
réalisé à la bonne date est déterminant
pour qu' il soit efficace le faire ni
trop tôt ni trop tard donc en effet nous
nous sommes confrontés en ce moment à la
difficulté un que vous évoquez c'est à
dire que les accès aux tests étant plus
compliqué en termes de délais il est
important pour nous de dire à la
personne en effet de s'y prendre tôt
pour faire pour faire faire sa demande
de tests et nous sommes amenés à lui
demander aussi s'est elle a besoin
d'accompagnement c'est à dire que
premièrement nous sommes en capacité de
lui fournir les listes des laboratoires
qui pratiquent l'examen et nous sommes
aussi en capacité de lui proposer la
mise en place d'un prélèvement à
domicile lorsque c'est par exemple une
personne qui
avoir des difficultés de mobilité
d'autonomie pour se déplacer et qui pour
ce pauvre pour laquelle ce type de
mesure serait plus approprié donc ça
c'est le premier point
ensuite le fait que la personne soit
enregistrée dans notre base en fait
contacter qu'ovide et en sortie
d'entretiens nous lu des livres ont
aussi un courrier en fait qui permet de
récapituler l'entretien convient d'avoir
avec elles
et tous ces éléments permettent aux
laboratoires d'identifier au guichet
entre guillemets qui l'a bien face à lui
une personne qui est personnes
contactées qui donc est prioritaire dans
la mise en place du test par opposition
peut-être à des personnes qui se ferait
tester de façon sûre la propre
initiative
voilà donc ces deux éléments me
paraissent à noter sur la conduite de
l'entretien également madame courez vous
disais tout à l'heure que nous avons en
fait un certain nombre de questions qui
nous amène à pouvoir détecter des
difficultés par rapport à l' isolement
et c'est pas nécessairement en effet des
difficultés de précarité mais tout
simplement des difficultés de logement
et c'est dans cette
dans cette situation que nous sommes
amenés à proposer à la personne de
prendre contact avec la cellule
territoriale d'appui à l'isolément qui
peut mettre en place un hébergement
externe soit pour la personne qu vide
soit pour l'un de ses proches d'une
érable par exemple en fonction de la
situation ça peut être plus pertinent
que ça soit soit la personne malade soit
au contraire quelqu'un a protégé au sein
de son foyer qui va être peut héberger
dans un hébergement temporaire est donc
ce sont exactement dans ce type de
situation qu'on propose à personne de
reprendre contact avec les cellules
territoriales d'appui à lise allemand
qui doit pouvoir leur proposer des d
accompagnement spécifique et puis
peut-être simplement sur la
participation vous dire que dans les
personnes que nous avons au téléphone et
je vous disais qu'on en avait près de
40000 tous les jours on a finalement
nous en tout cas
côté assurance maladie assez peu de
personnes qui refusent de répondre à nos
questions ou qui refusent qu'on les
enregistrant base ou qui se montrent en
fait manifestement non coopératives
on estime en fait cette cette proportion
autour des 3% donc vous dire que c'est
ça reste marginal voilà sur la question
de la prise en charge des tests dans les
différents laboratoires donc là dessus
c'est un même niveau de prise en charge
quel que soit le laboratoire partie fait
les tests donc ça a été fixé dans la
nomenclature donc effectivement le
gouvernement a fait le
le choix de lever l'obligation de
prescription parce que c'est vrai que
ont plafonné en termes de niveau de
tests à réaliser
donc ça ça a changé les choses
effectivement on a vu que du coup il y
avait énormément de recours aux tests de
manière spontanée également bien sûr est
donc maintenant vous avez vu que le
gouvernement a engagé une stratégie de
priorisation là dessus nous faudra voir
quels quel impact elle a juste nous
derrière ça eu une conséquence aussi sur
le racing
j'aimerais insister sur ce point c'est à
dire que au départ comme on vous le
disait le tout politique de sur le
tracking
elle est fondée sur les médecins
libéraux et les établissements de santé
et bien sûr l'assurance maladie comme on
a levé la prescription
il ya eu effectivement cette question de
du recours aux tests massif spontanée et
puis la question du médecin c'est à dire
est ce que le médecin était prévenue à
temps du fait que son patient et est
dépisté positif pour qu'il puisse lui
donner les consignes sur les malheureux
court masc en isolement et qu'ils
puissent engager le tracé lui même donc
actuellement nous avons toute une
campagne avec les médecins et les
assurés pour redire aux assurés que même
s'ils sont allés se faire dépister
spontanément ils doivent aller voir
l'entente ça nous paraît absolument
important qu'ils aillent voir le médecin
même si quand ils sont positifs même
s'ils sont allés faire dépister
spontanément faut qu'ils aillent voir
leur médecin quand ils sont positifs
pour que le médecin puisse vraiment lors
de leur expliquer les consignes on pense
que ça sera aussi quand même quelque
chose qui va permettre derrière une
meilleure appropriation des consignes et
donc un meilleur respect de ces
consignes et donc ça favorisera la
qualité de de ce qui est fait en termes
de geste par hyères et d'isolement et
que derrière le médecin puisse compléter
ou engager le
le recensement des quatre montagnes mais
en tous les cas madame la sénatrice même
niveau de présence
quel que soit le laboratoire fait alors
il ya peut-être effectivement des sujets
par rapport à la laboratoire vétérinaire
qui n'ont peut-être pas pu se raccorder
aussi rapidement que les autres aux
halles ou thisted ep
mais dans l'ensemble l'outil cidep est
largement rempli par les laboratoires à
voir que par ailleurs nous on a fixé une
condition de prise en charge est à dire
qu on ne rembourse pas le texte
si l'outil cidep n'est pas remplie donc
ça c'est quand même quelque chose qui
était essentiel pour garantir d'avoir un
outil si des peuples et transmission
cryptée de toute façon qu'ils peuvent se
faire en dehors nous sur les
laboratoires vétérinaires peut-être
qu'ils ont utilisé la messagerie
sécurisée de santé sûr mais je ne sais
pas du tout comment ça s'est passé je
n'ai pas d'éléments horrifié voilà c'est
qu'elle saddam n'y at il pas eu dans la
logique de 2,2 ce que les expliquer
notre côté de confusion entre une une
stratégie de deux de test de deux tests
diagnostiques par rapport aux tests de
dépistage quoi il ya une vraie confusion
dans cette stratégie là et les gens ne
n'arrive plus à comprendre parce que
c'est pas la même approche entre un test
diagnostique les cas contacts etc à la
positivité ce qu'il veut pas dire
forcément dire la personne est
contagieuse qui se complique mais entre
les tests de dépistage notamment massif
où il n'y a pas eu il y aurait pu y
avoir une stratégie différente avec des
plateformes territorialisée etc
non mais non mr pensée par rapport à ça
non mais on voit que il ya eu d une
évolution très clairement c'est à dire
qu'au départ c'était on était
diagnostiquée et tout le dépistage et le
racing était fondé sur un médecin enfin
c'était ça c'était le recours aux
médecins
voilà exactement médecin qui a un
patients symptomatiques qui on va se
faire dépister
après effectivement on a cherché à
encourager la politique de test est à ce
point critique mais
n'oublie pas nos stratégies de dépistage
salue un peu confus juger les remontées
qu'on l'a du terrain oui après juste
rappeler quand même qu'il ya eu d'autres
avant d'arriver à la levée de la
prescription posés par le gouvernement
il ya eu toute une série de campagnes
qui ont été menées sous à l'instigation
des ars pour renforcer le dépistage sur
certains territoires où il y avait le
des arguments dans le sens qu'on
pressentait que sur ces territoires là
le virus circule et plus vite que
d'autres plus vite qu'ailleurs
et puis des territoires dans lequel on
savait qu'on avait des clusters et donc
il était particulièrement important
derrière d'engager des actions sur ces
territoires donc nous assurance maladie
on a travaillé en étroite collaboration
avec les ars et on a mis à disposition
nous nos capacités de mes lignes
d'identification des gens sur les
territoires pour leur envoyer des
courriers et les inciter à aller se
faire dépister sur ces territoires
et puis effectivement après le
gouvernement a considéré que ces
politiques ne permettaient pas
d'atteindre un niveau de tests suffisant
et donc il ya eu la levée de la
prescription est aujourd'hui
l'engagement politique sur la
priorisation dont il faudra voir comment
elle se met en oeuvre concrètement parce
que les délais qui est actuellement qui
vont se résorber probablement avec le
changement de stratégie ça pénalise
votre travail quand même puisqu'il ya il
ya quand même un vrai retard on a tous
eu des remontées on a même un collègue
qui nous incitaient qu'ils étaient même
pas et derrière contacté alors qu'il y
avait une réunion familiale et c'est
donc derrière il ya encore des trous
dans la raquette semble-t-il et
notamment aussi tous ces efforts qui
sont en bien réalisées grâce à votre
implication aussi derrière on n'a pas
les résultats des tests on n'a pas de
rendez vous pour les tests etc
la personne effectivement elle s'est
largement balader a pu contaminer donc
on perd tout efficace là un sujet centre
voilà donc véritablement faut revenir
clairement vous avez peut-être des
préconisations à nous faire vous qui
connaissez bien le système
ben non mais nous il nous il nous semble
que ça promet
l'expert non mais il faut prioriser
enfin je pense que la politique de
priorisation aussi la politique engagée
par le gouvernement sur la
diversification des types de tests aussi
devrait faciliter plus dit fier et
permettre parce que c'est bien un
objectif qu'on a tous c'est d'avoir un
test avec un accès au test le plus
rapide possible et un résultat du test
voilà voilà voilà c'est ça effectivement
vous avez complètement raison qui
conditionne le succès après du trading
ça c'est sûr et derrière bien sûr de l'
isolement donc là on va voir avec la
nouvelle stratégie qui est développé par
maintenant comment ça se passe mais il
faut savoir juste un point quand même
c'est que les laboratoires bien sûr sont
très très très sensible aux difficultés
rencontrées par la population et je
voudrais quand même insisté aussi sur le
fait que nous d'un point de vue
financier
je pense que les laboratoires voilà on
les moyens de recruter aussi pour parce
qu'on voit bien qu'il ya un sujet
d'accueil dans les laboratoires
d'organisation concrète de comment ça se
passe
et donc voilà donc on estime non
assurance maladie en tous les cas que
sur cette politique d'accompagnement des
laboratoires niveau financier pour leur
donner les moyens d'être en capacité de
gérer ce volume de test là dessus nous
avons été au rendez vous
donc c'est pas ils ont les moyens
derrière pour pardon en naso pharyngé
etc
oui c'est ça aujourd'hui ils ont elle
est prête et le prix à être un prix
qu'on regarde européen le prix est un
prix qui couvre largement les
prélèvement salivaire vont peut-être
aussi arranger les choses
c'est la diversification de la politique
enfin là bien sûr les tests salivaires
faciliteront le prélèvement puisqu'il
suffira voilà donc ça devrait donc le
des plus faciles ça pourra être fait
aussi bas sarkoy moi ça nécessite mans
aussi d'équipements de protection
externe donc tout ça devrait faciliter
les prélèvements le recueil et du coup
derrière devrait faciliter les choses en
terme de d'obtention de délais rapides
bien sûr merci catherine des roches oui
moi j'entends bien ce débat entre
dépistage et le diagnostic
néanmoins quand on sait le nombre de
personnes positives asymptomatiques ça
aussi du sens de faire un dépistage
massif alors après on engorge c'est là
où l'organisation doit se faire mais
intellectuellement c'est aussi une
question qui n'est pas qu'il n'ait pas à
évacuer quand on sait combien de
personnes soit symptomatique le fait de
pouvoir les les dépister sûr vous avez
évoqué mais je sais pas si ça dépend ça
dépend pas de votre votre structure au
sein du cpm le coup on a quand même des
des notifications de coûts dans d'autres
pays européens qui sont qui sont moitié
pratiquement en espagne et autres j'ai
même vu des chiffres qui me paraissait
très très bas et qu'ils sont peut-être
un peu un peu farfelu entre guillemets
néanmoins et des coups très très bas et
le coût total enfin des coûts inférieurs
et le coût total sur l'assurance maladie
sera quand même bien bien différent d'un
pays à l'autre
il est important faut-il le rappeler
quand même 250 millions d'euros par mois
tu est effectivement par exemple on est
autour de 73 73 euros le test un tout
compris un ledez plus le prélèvement
plus je sais qu'ils doivent donner les
informations non cidep effectivement
dans d'autres pays dont l'allemagne
on est autour d'un peu plus de 54 enfin
de 54 euros donc voila voila après il
paraissait important qu effectivement
sur une sur une feinte sujet de cette
nature les laboratoires est vraiment les
moyens de s'organiser de recruter extra
et qu'ils aient les moyens de conduire
et d'être au rendez vous sur cette
politique de test merci laurence cohen
oui moi je n'ai pas eu réponse monsieur
sportys et à ma question sur les deux
systèmes voilà et puis du coup j'ai une
femme est venue pour vous mesdames
qu'elle est l'intervention de
l'assurance maladie par rapport aux
tests qui sont pratiqués en pharmacie
des trod ces voix là est ce que est ce
que ça c'est aussi ça fait partie de
comment les tests antigénique un des
trois de petits génies qu'en corse et
ceux qui se sont déjà opposées à cergy
oui en fait j'ai été alerté par des
personnes qui donc ont fait c'est est
donc jamais eu de réponse l'horoscope
n'a pas eu de réponse sur les
irrégularités territoriales on le sait
il ya des endroits où il ya une liste
d'attenté riz mais il ya des endroits
effectivement mon secteur rural n'ya pas
d'attendre du tout alors que dans la
grande ville de reims à côté il ya une
attente qui est quand même qui devient
un peu l'eau est-ce que vous avez une
cartographie qui vous permet un petit
peu de voir les aussi les trous dans la
raquette et voir quelles sont les
territoires qui sont plus concernés que
d'autres vous avez fait un retour
justement d'expérience pour voir comment
on peut combler cette inégalité
territoriale
c'est encore trop tôt en fait
aujourd'hui de tout le pilotage en fait
de cet accès aux tests et fait parler
ce qui cartographie en fait au sein de
chaque territoire et qui essaient en
effet deux d'apporter des moyens
complémentaires puisque on sait très
bien que le taux d'incidence est
beaucoup plus fort en ville en effet que
dans des zones moins peuplées et donc
même si à plus de laboratoires aussi en
ville il n'empêche que ceux ci sont
beaucoup plus fortement sollicité donc
là la supervision entre guillemets à la
fois sur la chaîne d'approvisionnement
pour que les laboratoires ne manquent
pas des produits nécessaires à la
réalisation du test est également des
appuis en ressources humaines le
qualifiant tout ça ça fait partie en
effet de la stratégie de veille de la rs
vous avez donc ça la rs que nous
poserons la question mais il ya un coût
que quand même qu'il est très lourd pour
l'assurance maladie certains pays ne
rembourse pas systématiquement tous les
tests sous les rembourse pas contient un
délai supérieur à tant de temps vous
avez élaboré une stratégie comme cela
fait une proposition vous êtes associé à
cette stratégie ou bien vous vous êtes
le simplement au bout de la chaîne on
vous dit fait comme ça on participe à la
réflexion mais c'est vrai que le
décideur sur
c'est le ministère qui définit la
politique de test enfin ça c'est sûr
voilà et on a été associé par exemple
quand je vous signalais qu' on ne
rembourse pas normalement un test quand
le laboratoire n'a pas n'a pas rempli
l'ensemble des informations dans cidep
donc voilà donc ça c'est nous sur les
trois de madame juste les trois dons sur
l'as actuellement les trolls autorisé
c'est lorsqu'on veut savoir si on a été
contaminé ou pas donc cela ne sont pas
pris en charge
aujourd'hui sont effectivement délivrés
par les pharmaciens et non non pris en
charge mais c'est me voilà donc là c'est
plutôt c'est pas pour savoir si
actuellement je suis porteur du virus
etc pour savoir si j'ai été contaminé ou
pas donc c'est un des éléments et c'est
vrai que pour l'instant c'est d'accès
ouais voilà et c'est dax et enfin j'ai
l'impression qu'on prend pas en charge
donc on n'a pas de chiffres mais j'ai
l'impression que c'est assez limité en
tous les cas en terme de
de délivrance par les par les
pharmaciens
mais les tests antigénique vont être
plus rapide mais il y aura toujours un
prélèvement nasopharyngé qui va
nécessiter de manoeuvre voilà et donc la
question aujourd'hui là où le ministère
en train de travailler c7 est
antigénique dans quel cadre on les y
privilégie où paris vient la pression à
tj voilà exactement mais la stratégie
elle est en cours de définition ce
président est monsieur sportive pour les
questions qui vous réponse merci
monsieur le vice président je crois
qu'il y avait enfin j'ai synthétiser
l'ensemble des questions de mesdames et
sénatrices autour de trois volets
j'espère que j'ai oublié aucun des
volets un volet sur le respect de la
cybersécurité deux aspects la vie privée
un volet sur la pédagogie un volet sur
la question des installations sur le
premier volet vous avez entièrement
raison faut toujours avoir une très
grande humilité dans le monde numérique
il n'y a aucun système technique qui
avec 1 0% de possibilités on va dire
d'atteinte à certaines fonctionnalités
dont et c'est pour ça que les sujets de
respect de cybersécurité aspect la vie
privée doivent donner lieu à un travail
permanent avec un plan de la efficace
ion qu'il ya des failles auxquelles on
n'a pas pensé qui en fait sont détectés
donc donc un travail permanent sur ces
sujets et vous avez entièrement raison
il n'y a pas de système 0% on peut juste
donner les meilleures garanties
possibles
il n'y a pas un petit élément par votre
question je le répète il n'ya pas de
données de géolocalisation dans le cadre
de ce top convient donc ça cette
question là par contre elle est
elle est traitée oui ces données
circulent après c'est la question de la
nature des données et c'est pour ça que
c'est le choix qu'a fait la france que
d'avoir des données qui ne soient pas
des données médicales
voilà pourquoi je le dis avec mes mots
donc un travail permanent et sur cette
question de la réassurance de notre
espèce si persécutés respect de la vie
privée le sujet du contrôle démocratique
le rôle des autorités administratives
indépendantes et clé je citais la cnil
la cnil a jugé que sur deux points lors
du premier contrôle de la cnil qui a été
effectué sur ce top cow vides il y avait
deux points qui étaient importants je
cite ces exemples qui était
l'utilisation à un moment d'une dune une
brique logicielle de google pour éviter
ce qu'on appelle un recaptcha pour
éviter les attaques par des robots de
notre système
d'une part et d'autre part la non mise
en oeuvre non déploiement d'un filtre de
minimisation de remonter des données la
cnil a jugé cela conduit à une mise en
demeure en juillet qu'il fallait qu'on
avance sur ces deux sujets les parties
de notre feuille de route mais il y
avait une urgence qui fait qu'on avait
arbitré que ces deux sujets sur lequel
on s'était engagé n'avait pas encore été
mis en oeuvre au moment du contrôle de
la cnil
ils ont été remis dié et il ya une
clôture de la mise en demeure le 3 juin
le 3 septembre pardon ce qui montre
l'importance sur ces sujets cyber
sécurité et respect de la vie privée des
organes de contrôle sur le deuxième
sujet qui concerne la pédagogie donc le
sujet est effectivement être capable
d'expliquer en face de craintes
légitimes sur des sujets où il peut y
avoir des dérives quels sont les
éléments de l'assurance que l'on a c'est
la première fois à ma connaissance que
l'on discute d'un logiciel au parlement
et donc derrière c'est quand même un
grand élément de
de retour d'expérience c'est 2-2 de
maturité des deux côtés du côté de ceux
qui ont une connaissance technique et du
côté des décideurs politiques que d'être
capable de trouver un bon terrain de
discussion et puis partant après pour
les citoyens donc là pour moi si je fais
un pas de côté on a beaucoup appris
à l'occasion de ce de cette question de
la pédagogie qui pourront pas vraiment
dans les deux sens sur les systèmes
numériques sur les systèmes logiciels
c'est pas courant c'est sujet soit
discuté au parlement à ma connaissance
et je trouve qu'un petit paradoxe par
ailleurs sur le fait qu'on dénonce sur
des réseaux sociaux et éventuellement
des atteintes possibles à la vie privée
ce qui participe on va dire de la
question de la maturité numérique
globale collective que nous avons sur
cette question de la pédagogie à une
question qui a été une sous question qui
a été posée sur le made in france
voilà donc là je je pense j'ai tout à
l'heure que doit y avoir un élément de
de fierté sur le fait que la france a
fait l'investissement de dérouler un an
sans un programme de r&d de bout en bout
sur le sujet ce qui a des implications
en termes de retours d'expérience en
termes de maîtrise et médine france ne
veut pas dire qu'on est renvoyé à au
plan calcul au minitel etc
je pense qu'on doit avancer en humilité
voilà et de troisième volet concernait
la désinstallation donc vraiment je vais
dans la droite ligne de ce que j'ai dit
tout à leur conception extrêmement
respectueuse de la vie privée on ne sait
absolument pas le pourquoi d'une
désinstallation parce qu'on n'a pas de
on n'a pas de gérard pas trouvé le terme
français jugent mon excuse on n'a pas de
monitoring on n'a pas de remontée
d'informations
précise sur les terminaux sur les
versions des terminaux et c'est
d'ailleurs un sujet qui est directement
lié à la conception initiale de
l'application et qui peut être qu'il
peut éventuellement évoluer donc on ne
sait pas pourquoi les gens désinstalle
on a des hypothèses une des hypothèses
sait on constate par exemple j'ai parlé
de fer d'élasticité positive à la
promotion de ce top cow vide
il ya aussi universités négative si un
article dans la presse sort
explicitant que pour telle et telle
raison il ya une faille majeure de
respect de la vie privée qui fait que
c'est une application liberticide
on constate c mi juin je crois on
constate une désinstallation massive
pendant quelques jours donc il ya aussi
une nécessité la promo là on va dire
négative
c'est une application c'est le plus
structurelle qui est extrêmement
taiseuse si vous permettez cette
expression dans sa conception elle ne
dit pas grand-chose cette application
vous savez pas si elle fonctionne de
manière quand vous allez dans votre
poche
voilà c'est une conception cetc à 180°
de ce qu'est une application plus qu'une
application elles demandent votre
attention elle est faite pour demander
votre attention pour demander votre
interactions c'est une conception qu'on
a fait dès le début comme ça pour plein
de raisons liées notamment à comment
dire à la question on va dire des
craintes numérique
c'est un choix qui a été fait on est en
train de revenir dessus un peu pour le
faire éventuellement évoluer pour qu'il
y ait plus d'interaction pour
utilisateurs qu'ils soient plus son
contrôle de son de ce que fait son
application et on pense que ce vol
étaient eux jouent pour une grande part
aussi sur de la désinstallation enfin de
ce que l'on peut voir comme retour il ya
un système d'exploitation android pour
le pal nommé donc 80% du parc mobile
français sur lequel l'application est en
veille
il ya un petit bandeau qui explicite que
l'application stop qu'ovide est là pour
vous protéger
peut-être que pour ça on ne peut rien
c'est un c'est une contrainte
enfin c'est une donnée de ce système
d'exploitation
peut-être que pour certaines personnes
ça peut être anxiogène je ne sais pas
mais c'est une des hypothèses que l'on a
voilà et mais malheureuse mais ça c'est
quelque chose qui est contrainte donc on
pense qu'avoir une puis parfois je vais
évoquer tout à l'heure sur un parc
extrêmement hétérogène
on peut avoir aussi des cycles
d'installation ça se passe mal parce que
la version est mal supporté le terminal
est mal supporté des installations parce
que ça n'a pas marché j'essaye de
réinstaller on a tout cet ensemble et ça
veut dire qu'il ya pas mal de petites
actions de notre part à notre place pour
essayer d'y remédier voilà je fais le
tri qui s'usent aussi j'avais entendu
alors on a certains coupent la nuit je
ne sais quoi enfin remettre
on a créé des études batterie lors de la
phase de développement mais ces études
batterie qu'on continue à faire
d'ailleurs mais mais qui n'arrive pas
être exhaustive sur un parc qui est
extrêmement hétérogène yahia part on n'a
pas quelques smartphones qui a quelques
uns font 70 % du parc on a des centaines
de terminaux qui eux mêmes ont des
versions de systèmes d'exploitation
cette couche logicielle qui peuvent être
très vieille parce que les gens c'est
leur droit n'ont pas voulu les remettre
à jour où très récente donc où c'est un
peu fractales les combinaisons que l'on
a
voilà donc nous on avait fait des études
batterie qui ne montraient pas un impact
majeur il faut qu'on continue à les
faire parce que peut-être que
probablement que sur certains terminaux
avec certaines versions du système
d'exploitation via un pack batteries et
pour ces personnes ça peut jouer voilà
on n'a pas d'éléments statistiques là
dessus en tout cas voilà enfin derrière
c'est sûr qu'il faut que les français
acceptent cela ce sera comme le problème
de la vaccination
voilà donc il ya encore de la pédagogie
à faire parce que je pense que si on
l'expliquent bien ils sont quand même
capable de largement bien comprendre
toutes ces données de protection
collective
merci il n'y a pas d'autres questions
dont conclut notre audition la merci
mesdames messieurs
rendez vous à 15 heures pour les
commissaires je crois
on de mal à me parler
c'était l'audition de
sénat sur la gestion de la crise
sanitaire une audition qui abordait les
aspects numérique de la lutte contre
l'épidémie
c'est la fin de cette émission merci de
l'avoir suivi rendez vous à 15h pour
l'audition de la ministre des armées
florence parly devant la commission
denquête une audition qui est à suivre
notamment sur notre site internet
publicsenat.fr
je vous souhaite une très bonne journée
sur public sénat
le